[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
hi friday night
kind of intro is that seriously any
intro i do he's going to be like what
the [ __ ] was this
a girl i don't know what that was
getting a wide world of sports or
something
the this is howard cosa
[Laughter]
the wide world of sports
yeah the was it the victory the the
thrill of victory and the agony of
defeat
and then he was showing the [ __ ] yeah
i kind of felt
i mean i was impressed i was a little
kid that was that was the seventh day
[ __ ] the uh this is gonna be a
pretty good show
trying to take us a while to [ __ ] get
warmed up thomas don't want to do this
one for a really long time
so he was very very happy when it
finally won the poll
yeah did a lot of research on this case
this is a pivotal case
in the world of just law enforcement uh
civilian
uh firearm ownership and the philosophy
that
of of of the police forces of the united
states
connor was the crooks of
modern law enforcement actually happened
with this case
you're going to see why yeah it was kind
of like changed the game
yeah all right and in the guns
american gun culture these two offenders
here man they had some weird-ass
equipment that they made themselves they
they were these these dudes were dummies
but they weren't that dumb
they they they did some cool [ __ ]
they they really over thought
how to rob a bank and put a lot of
effort
into [ __ ] that ended up basically
getting their asses killed anyway this
is not really how you rob a bank but
they thought it was
this was like some [ __ ] out of heat well
somebody just
asked if uh was the movie heat based on
this it wasn't actually i thought heat
came out a little bit before this and
actually i think
and i could be totally wrong on this but
i thought that
these robbers even got a couple of ideas
from heat
so maybe it was around the same time in
the zeitgeist of the era
these were two big [ __ ] dudes that
was another thing that made them
unique they were big [ __ ] uh
bodybuilders
[ __ ] bumping some major roid rage
they were heavily armed and they knew a
lot about small arms
they uh made their own full automatic
weapons their own custom
rigs uh emel's uh dissipator
is a often copied firearm in the firearm
world
people try to mock up that weapon that
he used it was a modified ar-15
it was a bushmaster and it was just a
cool looking little rig he thought up of
some cool
mods for that and uh you know
guns can end up on either side of the
[ __ ] law and uh as far as
a quote bad guy gun ammo made up made a
pretty good one
um you know and a lot of people
throughout american history did that
too you know clive barrels bar pretty
famous
the modifications that he did to that
again motorized bandits and armed
bandits the ones that ended up going
down in american history usually at
least knew some
things about guns and they did train a
little bit
uh i'd say the barrel gang trained more
but these guys
were pretty well trained but they were
self-trained
they didn't have any formalized training
outside bodybuilding
uh but they got a lot of stuff right and
a lot of stuff wrong we're gonna talk
about it
um and this wasn't actually their first
robbery no
it was their last spoiler alert yeah but
it wasn't their first one
yeah we're going to get into the details
yeah and
prepper pov also points out yes they did
make their own body armor yeah they made
their own body armor they did it on
modified weapons converting stuff to
full auto
this this case kind of gave
a lot of law enforcement and legal types
in the blue states it gave them a
[ __ ] heart attack because
these guys showed people that civilian
leadership that really has no
military knowledge or background showed
them what two
determined and skilled people were
capable of
you know they held most of the lapd at
bay for several hours
i think it was two hours no it was 44
minutes 44 minutes okay
it seemed like a long time i was
watching it live unfold on television
yeah
pretty much and actually if you go on
youtube you can still find the footage
of it
everywhere because actually this was
actually really famous it happened back
in 1997
and uh news helicopters were on the
scene almost immediately i
filmed pretty much the whole thing i
watched these two dudes shoot it out
with the police live
i watched them both die live it was
[ __ ]
like wow you couldn't believe that you
saw it one thing
that amazes me about this [ __ ] is that
the firepower that that had that they
had
and then all of the [ __ ] that happened
um you know they were firing what they
fired like a ridiculous amount of rounds
cops were firing back at them the swat
team came everything like that
and it amazes me that there were a lot
of injuries
a lot of cops were shot but none of the
cops died the only people that died
were the two robbers yeah um
having experienced myself in a lot of
infantry training being
from good light infantry units you know
i'm from the first in the 506 and and
first 327 recon platoon also known as
tiger force
served during the times when the u.s
army was real strong in the [ __ ]
early to mid 90s
and then later on my career ended up
doing some
i guess you could say working for law
enforcement and
uh some units at the [ __ ] federal
level as a contractor
um mostly in a training and support role
though but
the
i kind of think that they were mad at
the cops
they i'm not sure they were using
suppressive fire techniques we can get
in that middle
they weren't really using a lot of aimed
or precision fire
which meant and based upon what they s
what they were saying what they were
saying to the cops they were using
something i'm kind of getting ahead of
myself
they were more to me watching them
with a trained eye they were more intent
on getting away and holding the cops at
bay
than they were killing the cops yeah i
think
they just wanted to get away with the
money because they had done it before
like i said and they because they had
done a couple bank robberies prior to
this and got like what was it one and a
half million two million something like
that
and i think they suspect that they had
also robbed an armored car at some point
so they had done like some successful
bank robberies prior
but they had never killed anybody no
they did kill uh one armored car
oh they did guy like previously yeah
back in 96 i think it was
that's right yeah i forgot about that
they did they did kill one of the guards
and they did the other one
right and maybe they killed that guy and
didn't really feel that good about it
it's hard to say some of the things that
they were doing were terror tactics
yeah and usually you do that kind of
stuff to try to avoid from killing
somebody
in other words you're using like
overwhelming intimidation on the enemy
to try to get them to run or to leave
you alone or to try to get it so where
you don't have to kill that person they
were doing [ __ ] like that
a dude that really wants to kill you
doesn't say a [ __ ] word you don't
even see him
yeah shoots in the back of the head from
[ __ ] 150 meters
all right you never even knew he was
there but a dude that's yelling and
screaming and making slurs against you
and stuff and
shooting at you is usually you know it's
like a lot of
bark and not a whole lot of bite you
know you're trying to keep
keep you at bay you're using a lot of
intimidation tactics
yeah i mean that's what they trained us
to do but in a very different way you
know i mean like we used to we were
trying to do things like double tapping
in kill zones during the [ __ ] sweep
in other words
not taking any prisoners but killing the
wounded you know the units that i was in
that was the in the era of our times
also a lot of [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
psychological [ __ ]
cussing screaming yelling during charges
and [ __ ]
uh you know you do everything you can to
puff yourself
up in the face of the enemy to try to
get them to break and run
because it's a lot easier to shoot
somebody in the back than it is to shoot
somebody in the front while they're
[ __ ] returning fire
well yeah you know what i mean kind of
goes without that yeah
you're not there to fight fair yeah get
that out of your [ __ ] mind warfare is
not fair it's not a fair stand-up fight
it's organized murder and if you're not
doing it that way then you're wrong
you're going to die
yeah trace render is saying uh wouldn't
the rounds have been armor-piercing i
did yeah
most of their rounds were they did have
a lot of armor-piercing rounds and the
thing about it was that
they were um a lot of their weapons were
illegally modified and the cops didn't
have anything
yeah to that until this i mean the swat
team did but it took like 18 minutes for
the swat team to go okay
i'm gonna reverse something jenny said
she's gonna get mad but
she her it's her sources many of the
sources say that it was over piercing
rounds that's a lie
they weren't the only thing that they
had it was it was
civilian grade a small armed rifle
ammunition in 556
and 762 by 39 soviet and what they were
calling armor piercing is the california
prosecutors would call it armor piercing
and what it was it was steel corner
renko basic
steel coordinate rinco ak routes it is
not an armor-piercing round
now some states classified it as that
but it does not appear
it does not penetrate armor any better
than just a regular lead round they put
us mild steel core in the center of some
of the chinese communist
762 rounds to displace the lead
because steel is cheaper than lead so
yeah it's a little bit lighter
in the core but it's cheaper and
a lot of them had steel case
steel jacketed bullets that were copper
washed
but that's also does not aid in
penetration or armor penetration
it's just cheaper than using solid
copper you got to have
a jacket over the bullet when it's
moving that fast going down the barrel
or it'll just foul the barrel up uh
leave a lot of lead deposits behind so
you
normally would put a copper jacket
around to help lubricate it
but copper's expensive it's cheaper to
just
put a thin sheet metal around it that's
a lot cheaper and then just wash it with
copper because it's not going to be
going down the rifling barrels for very
long
so that's just one way to get around a
couple
cents cheaper per round and you can make
it a lot faster it's not those this
doesn't
have strategic metals involved but at
the time that all this [ __ ] came out
basically california wanted to ban all
guns so they were trying
to demonize every aspect of the
equipment that these guys used
but it wasn't actually just regular [ __ ]
it wasn't anything real
exotic you could get that ammo
everywhere anywhere
true armor piercing is something that's
been covered in teflon
it'll lubricate its way through body
armor or it's got tongues and steel core
which is
real hard real dense you know it's kind
of like
the closest you're going to get to like
depleted uranium you know depleted
uranium is very expensive
but tungsten is similar it's a lot
cheaper that would be considered armor
piercing
but just not mild steel core that very
technical [ __ ]
yes lizzie b said after that shootout is
when cops started carrying uh assault
rifles exactly yeah because they were uh
out gunned on those
right this was in an era where a lot of
us
police in the blue states weren't
getting real good support
their their political leadership really
didn't like police
and they definitely didn't like guns
they wanted to give those guys just
revolvers
but they had been sitting ducks for a
civilian that could get their hands on
decent weaponry so you know the
the police unions demanded that every
squad car should have access to some
kind of an ar-15
you know you know an assault rifle well
you caught an assault rifle that's
technically it's not an assault rifle
technically an assault rifle would have
been an m16 which is a full auto version
of an ar-15
they just wanted a semi-auto carbine
that was combat capable which would have
been an ar-15
and that way if they needed one they had
it they didn't have to go rob the damn
gun store to get it which is what they
eventually had to do to confront these
guys
very sensible there's nothing there's
nothing really powerful about an ar-15
it's
it's it's a it's a it's a it's a medium
what they call a
oh [ __ ] it's a very light carbine firing
a uh
a midsize rifle cartridge and 22 caliber
20 copper bullet behind a case about
that long
pretty effective but you know you're not
talking about
it you know a rifle a deer rifle
cartridge is a lot more powerful
you know what's interesting to me about
this though is that before this
whole [ __ ] happened because like i said
both of them had uh criminal records
not for anything like this necessarily
but uh i don't know if they were ever
convicted of that armored car
thing where that guy got killed but they
are pretty sure that that's who was
who was doing it but they actually got
pulled over for speeding
and there was like a whole [ __ ]
arsenal in their goddamn car like it was
they had all that stuff they also had
smoke bombs and all this other kind of
stuff and they got arrested for
something else but they didn't do that
much time
like they did maybe like 100 days or
something and then they let them back
out again and they gave them all their
[ __ ] back
yeah well they weren't like known
hardcore criminals during that time
and they didn't have you know what i
mean yeah well they pulled them over
they weren't
i don't think they were even felons they
could own i think they could own
firearms at that time
yeah i mean it must have been but like i
said i i don't know if they ever got
convicted of the [ __ ] earlier because
they had done they do suspect that they
had done like two or three bank
robberies prior and one armored car
where like one of the guards got killed
yeah
well they were suspected that means they
kind of put it on them it hasn't been
proven
but they probably did well it was the
same tactics like they used like the
same
tactics for it and i don't think they
ever caught them for it but they're
they're pretty sure that probably that
was that's
yeah yeah because it was like the exact
same [ __ ] um you know so and
you know maybe they were convicted
because like everybody says you know
they got 1.5 million from that one
before
and then you know this one didn't go the
way they uh had planned for it
right i remember the word i was looking
for it's called an intermediate rifle
cartridge
the ak and the ar-15 both fire
intermediate rifle cartridges
you have prepper bovs you say that yoga
uh it's um
in between a pistol cartridge
and a at a rifle cartridge so it's a
small rifle cartridge
it came out of world war ii when they
were trying to bend blend
rifles in with sub machine guns and you
end up with something that's kind of in
the middle which would have been like an
ak-47
kind of like a submachine gun firing a
small rifle cartridge
because submachine guns went away a
submachine gun is a full auto
small full auto weapon the fires pistol
rounds it's okay up close but beyond 100
meters it's just
there's not a so they wanted to the
assault rifle
merged to the abilities of the
submachine gun
and the rifle together into one weapon
that way you didn't have to issue two
separate weapons you could
issue one that would do both jobs
so let's see what everybody's doing in
the comments section yeah and i got a
couple of uh
shout outs as well okay go ahead i
wanted to give a thank you to
eric who was here last time i think on
our wednesday night show
and he asked if there was some way to
give a paypal donation and i guess he
figured out how to do it because he gave
us a very generous paypal donation so
thank you very much for that
i can't remember eric hill if you're
here or you show up later
um if you wanted a t-shirt or not i
don't think so because i didn't uh see
anything but if you do
let me know and we'll get that out to
you speaking of t-shirts
um okay so i wrote down like victor
wanted one
so we got that and uh david june
uh we're gonna get yours out as soon as
i had to order
like because i had run out of that size
so i had to like order a couple of those
and also uh no need for me to i just
ordered
uh the shirts all the shirts you wanted
with
like the the pet sizes and all that
other kind of stuff so all that stuff
should be here
in a day or two and then we'll get that
printed
and then get it out to you so i just
wanted everybody to know
that we got it under control mostly well
as under control as we have [ __ ] also
i pretty much finished the cookbook
and all i have to do now is i started
uploading it to lulu
um and i have to like i uploaded
the cover and i have to like upload the
all the inner pages because i had to get
an isbn and everything like that
after that i'm not really sure like i
said i usually use createspace so i
don't know how dulu works
i don't know if i'm going to have to
order like a proof copy
if i do i think i'd rather have a
physical proof copy that i can look at
rather than just because i know
createspace will let you like then we
can show it to them too
yeah like createspace will let you um
you know look at a proof copy online you
don't have to
order like a physical copy but i think
for something like this i think i'd
rather have a physical copy so i can see
if anything's [ __ ] up uh so
it might be a little while but like i
said it's it is finished the design and
everything
so i took way longer than i thought it
was going to
but at least it's [ __ ] done and so
i'm trying to get it all like uploaded i
got it like partially uploaded and i'm
still working on it
but so i just wanted everybody to know
that it is uh
you know i'm still doing it i'm still
doing it all right so
uh anything that you would like mr
robotta says what cookbook oh
well you must be new here yeah
the cold news working out for a year
yeah yeah it's been
i was supposed to have it done by
christmas but it's just other [ __ ]
intervened and i couldn't get to it and
like all this other kind of [ __ ] but
it's finally done now
we when did we get the idea i don't
remember when we got the idea because
people said man
you guys keep going off on like tangents
and talking about food and [ __ ]
and it's like and you know and he used
to be a cook and and he still cooks like
every day
made it made a big meatloaf today yeah
it makes meatloaf
i'm going to have some of that after the
show yeah uh but yeah so
uh somebody said why don't you write a
cookbook so we're like that's a good
idea
i didn't realize like how long it was
i've done book layouts before but
i don't know i'm so like picky about our
own [ __ ]
because i just i can't ever get it right
it's it and i'm never like happy with it
like i get it done and i'm just like i
don't like it i don't start all over
but then like finally i was just kind of
like i have to stop [ __ ] overthinking
it because i always [ __ ] do that
this is why everything takes me forever
like with other people's stuff i'm not
as bad as that but with my own stuff i'm
just kind of like i'll just sit there
and tinker with it forever
so you know but uh yeah so what else did
you have to uh add
anything granters hammer this guy who's
in the comment section i went to high
school with who was uh he's a retired
police officer
he said that because of this case they
issued him a um i think he said it was a
cult m4
sbr it's a short barrel rifle with the
three round burst on it which means that
was
that was an ex-military gun or at least
something slated for the military with
the three shot burst
we had that too when i was in the army i
hated three shot bursts though it
wouldn't reset you had to
let all three out if you didn't the next
pull might only be one or two depending
on how many you've unleashed after that
just kind of a crappy what they should
have put in that grand this is just a
really good semi-auto trigger like
something out of them
ke arms like a ke arms trigger a little
short throw
light trigger you pull that faster than
[ __ ] three round burst
if you wanted it and just more precision
just you know heavy military trigger
pulls
they kind of suck danny rolling
ghostface says they should have had a
getaway driver
probably i don't know if it would have
helped them necessarily
because the thing about it was that they
seemed to have like you said they
overthought everything they had cased
the place for a while beforehand
and they had all these plans and timing
and all this other kind of stuff
but you know as with anything else best
laid plans of mice and men
you know how that goes and it's like
some [ __ ] happened that they were not
anticipating
which they were over when i say they
were overthinking this
was they were overthinking it in this
way
they wanted these real high price
profile
takeover robberies where they go in
there just loaded for bear looking like
the [ __ ] terminator
then scare the [ __ ] out of everybody
[ __ ] shoot the place up on the inside
get past the tellers and get into the
vault and get where
where the big bucks was that's what they
wanted
yeah you can only you know when you're
doing [ __ ] like that man you're gonna
you're gonna attract a lot of a [ __ ]
tension you're gonna go right to the top
of the list they're gonna be gunning for
you
they had dudes that were doing real
subtle note jobs just going in there
with a damn piece of paper saying
i got a gun in my pocket give me what
you got in the register right there and
they had dudes that would do that for
decades and never get caught and over
time got more money
it's not splashing it's not splashing
over time pulled more money out of it
and never got killed
and when they got caught they didn't
have a gun on them so they couldn't
really get them for
armed robbery just kind of like bank
robbery they didn't get get
very much time for it it's called a note
job i mean if i was gonna rob a bank
that's totally the route i would get
right i would tell people that i had a
weapon but i wouldn't yeah they don't
actually have one because then if they
caught you you'd be like ah
they're not gonna get as much time right
and uh
you they get they they would get away
with it i don't know if they're still
able to get away with it the way they
were
but they were so low on the totem pole
that they and and the banks were insured
against them
it wasn't a big priority to go after
guys like that
and well because they're not hurting any
they're not endangering
anyone well really yeah well it's not
obvious they
well the law is going to say they are
okay that that they're endangering
people all right because they have to
they have to err on the side of call
well yeah they say the guy's a threat
but they they know the profile of dudes
that do note jobs
guys that are doing no jobs almost never
kill anybody they know when when that's
a no job they look they see it through
the camera
and just the the techniques that they're
doing and they go those
they're just trying to talk their way
into money yeah you know through threat
they catch them they do time but not as
much time as say a takeover robbery like
this
especially where you're engaging the
entire police department endangering
them all
shooting at them [ __ ] with surprised
everyone in the area
right and all of the civilians that were
in the bank and in the parking lots and
the company like the you know businesses
and houses around the bank
yeah just scaring the [ __ ] out of the
public at large you're a [ __ ] menace
to society
yeah big time and uh animal probably
could have been arrested and taken alive
but they made sure he died
those dudes didn't survive they did not
yeah
uh yeah dom the bomb said sorry i must
have been a little late what was the
shoot out about it was a bank robbery
went horribly horribly wrong um
and uh somebody said oh wait did they
take it away
okay did they take away oh did they
actually kill anyone inside the bank
they did not
no uh amazingly even though
like i said they shot like a ridiculous
what was it like 100 rounds or something
like that
um it was just like a ridiculous amount
of
uh firepower and i am amazed that they
did not kill anyone even accidentally
like i said a lot of people got shot or
injured
but nobody died except them yeah well
they were wearing
i don't wanna you know getting ahead of
the [ __ ] game but you know the cops
had body armor on
a lot of rounds are skipping off of the
ground a lot of them were getting shot
through cars
uh people were hiding behind trees uh
there was that guy that hid behind the
tree he almost died
yeah he was shocked but he but he lived
yeah amazingly i don't know how he did
because i was watching a documentary
about it i'm like how did that guy
[ __ ] survive holy [ __ ]
a lot of these cops that survived this
too uh didn't go back on a job either
this was their last day
well you can't blame them well they just
their heart wasn't in it
[Laughter]
someone came back there's been a lot of
cops been shot up bad you know they're
like they're like soldiers you know what
i mean they get shot up pretty bad
as soon as they heal up they're back on
the job you know some guys it's just in
them
grafters probably knows guys like that
he might be one of them i don't know if
he's ever shot
well you have to think too this happened
in 1997 and i feel like in la i was
watching
i watched a couple different
documentaries about this
um and one of the documentaries like one
woman she was
uh she worked for the police and she
said that at this time period in l.a
um there were like in los angeles there
were like three bank robberies a day
not all is like [ __ ] big and epic as
this one obviously yeah probably no jobs
but
but yeah she's like that there was a
thing where you know the word this was
it was kind of like a
a rash of bank robberies right around
this time period
yeah um so it's kind of like the bank
robbery unit or whatever like the the
cops that specialized in that were like
super busy like
all the time because it was always going
on some of these cops that walked off
the job because of this some of them you
know i've seen the interviews with them
i
didn't really kind of respect them that
much i think they just wanted that check
wanted that retirement check because
really
police department if it's working right
and it's a good police department
there's a lot of esprit de corps between
the cops that's like
your brotherhood that's that's your
tribe and it's just like
me when i was in the army if a guy got
injured or hurt i was in my hospital bed
fighting trying to fight out of my way
out of that coma to get back to my unit
you know because you're just trying to
get back to your unit you don't want the
unit to continue on without your help
because you see yourself as helping the
others
you know but you know i guess some
police departments aren't like that
maybe lapd wasn't like that
well maybe well the thing about it is
that you have to think too that's like
maybe some of these people were going to
retire anyway and it was just kind of
like well it's like you know it's just a
little sooner than
i let grandpa's chant chime in i'm just
saying i don't know yeah i'll let
grampus chime in on that when he thinks
about it
i feel like most of them this i saw one
documentary uh
i don't know if this was it was on
discovery or something like that it's
not on youtube but i think it was
originally on discovery the history
channel or whatever
but they have a whole series called
shootout um and it's
about all different shootouts so they
had a show about this one and they
talked to like a lot of the cops
and um a lot of the you have to think
too like there were a couple of cops
that actually like
went into the hot zone like while all
the uh
gunfire was going on like to actually
try and save
you know some of the cops that have been
shot yeah so you know so there was a lot
of that [ __ ] going on too
yeah well you're gonna have to kill me
you know man [ __ ] i'm not leaving the
unit that's just the way it is and if
if you get shot up you go back to your
unit with your [ __ ] purple heart
[ __ ] drop your nuts like a [ __ ] g
tell war stories and tell other people
what to do
that's tom's favorite thing that's what
you do
give me a [ __ ] coffee go get me some
[ __ ] coffee
you know it's just [ __ ] like that you
know what i mean what what are you gonna
do with fake meal
no no they get the coffee i'm talking
about
sorry if you said that to me i'd be like
no get your own phone
[Laughter]
your arms aren't broken hold on
my leg's healing my legs heal i've got
the [ __ ] purple heart hanging i'm
like limp your ass in there and get
drunk
i'm my [ __ ] though yeah mr robotta
says tom's one day away from retirement
yeah yeah right yep
all right so you want to like uh talk
about these [ __ ] now
yeah let's see what a man will do for
some coffee says proper pov
you know i understand that i understand
that i wish i could like order people to
go get me coffee
just like random ass people and they'd
bring it to me that'd be pretty rad
all right so excuse me a second oh yeah
all right
i swear to god this is only my first
drink
okay so these are the two dudes
that we're talking about larry phillips
jr
and emile matassarando as i think how
you pronounce
serrano yeah i think his mother he was a
romanian romanian guy i think he'd lived
here a while but i think he was born in
romania yeah yeah
these are big dudes they're like six
four
yeah and that's actually where they met
i don't know a huge amount about them
like
prior to this but they actually met uh
gold's gym and venice venice beach in
1989 and started hanging out together
yeah that's where arnie came from arnie
and
all his boys like i said that's very
famous like weightlifting scene there
muscle beach so they not only had that
in common
but they also had petty crime in common
yeah so you know they had something to
talk about
and they loved guns they [ __ ] loved
guns yeah they were super super
and they were pissed they were real
pissed um
at the state of california because the
state of california passed assault rifle
ban
and they were big into that kind of [ __ ]
so
according to some stuff that i picked up
on the peripheries
from friends that they had they kind of
saw
themselves as being like behind enemy
lines they did not like
the state of california in like its
government that's
dumb the bomb says what year did this
happen it was 1997.
1997. uh yeah so they were uh
both really into guns really into
weightlifting so they started like
hanging out together
now prior to them meeting uh larry
phillips actually did have
a criminal record um not nothing's
violent uh it was mostly like
shoplifting
um he was real into running like real
escape real estate scams
that kind of [ __ ] uh you know so kind of
penny 80.
uh emil i don't know if he had a record
prior to
meeting uh meeting larry but he
actually had a computer repair business
i guess he was like an electrical
engineer or something like that but i
guess the business wasn't doing all that
well or he had just started it so it
wasn't doing all that well because it
was new
now the two they all hung out together
and i guess they got the idea
since larry in particular was kind of
into
let's you know do some crimes and make
some money so they decided in back in
1993
that they were gonna rob an armored car
so
uh they did that that was in littleton
colorado
in july of 1993. now
later on that year they actually got
arrested this is what i was referring to
earlier
in glendale uh in california they got
arrested for speeding
now the cops searched their car um
and because larry had like surrendered
he had a concealed weapon
like on him so he surrendered so they
searched his car
they found uh two semi-automatic rifles
two handguns
uh sixteen hundred rounds of rifle
ammunition twelve hundred rounds
uh you know of various other things just
like a [ __ ] ton of stuff basically you
had a couple cases they have them
yeah radio scanners smoke bombs
improvised bombs
uh body armor and three different
california license plates
this doesn't look too good um when
you're driving around with that in your
car
and also you're speeding probably should
uh keep to the speed limit when you're
driving around with that kind of stuff
just a pro tip the improvised bombs part
i remember seeing that on the list i'm
not buying that but go ahead
because a homemade improvised munition
is an easy 10 years right there minimum
that's like having a machine gun and the
feds could pick that up
so i don't think we're getting the right
story on that i think what they had what
they found was
is things that could be used in infra in
improvised munitions i don't think there
was any explosives
yeah i'm just going by because that's a
big resource i saw said
i don't know i don't yeah i saw that i
don't believe it because that's a big
charge
if he had something like h.e or [ __ ]
anfo
or semtex or any kind of high explosive
even if it was just uh gunpowder packed
into a pipe bomb
they'll give you 10 years for that no no
ifs ands or buts
and they would have put it on him so i
don't i don't think that
that part is correct i think i think
it's a mistranslation a misunderstanding
they probably found something like
triggers
if if if any people know anything about
improvised munitions a trigger could be
anything and then like a clothes pin
a clothes pin with uh copper contacts on
the teeth
okay see what you could do is you could
put a wire on one side of the
clip one tooth of the clothespin and a
wire on the other side and make an
electric circuit and put a piece of
plastic in the middle with this
with a string so when you pull on the
string it pulls the plastic in between
the teeth and it makes the contact that
and that would set the bomb off that
would be a trigger well maybe it was
something like that
yeah the thing is that a trigger is not
illegal they just know what that is
well yeah and i mean the thing is if
your whole car
is full of [ __ ] like that yeah yeah yeah
then that looks a little suspicious look
suspicious but it wouldn't be illegal
it wouldn't be illegal and then yeah
technically it's not that that's why
he's really right right well again it's
not illegal to drive around with
duct tape and garbage bicycles and rope
and [ __ ] like that in your trunk
it just looks real fishy yeah that's all
that's all i'm saying
so uh so yeah so they get arrested now
they were charged
uh uh initially with conspiracy to
commit robbery because it looked uh very
clearly like that's what they were
planning on doing
um but they actually got really really
light sentences they both served 100
days
uh and then got three years probation
um after they were released three years
later they got pretty much all their
[ __ ] back
so there you go yeah so that's weird
they got him on something what was the
actual charge uh conspiracy to commit
robbery
okay all right so there was enough stuff
in there they could say you might be
making a robbery
yeah because that's like i said they
probably made them like take a plea deal
which probably pissed them off and they
probably were gonna do something crazy
it's my understanding based based on
well and they had done an armor they had
done it
before prior so yeah but the way the
attitude is well they didn't prove that
they didn't prove that we did that they
cheated that's that well these that's
how these guys think
my understanding was they just they had
very expensive tastes
they needed a lot of money in in
steroids and
[ __ ] they had uh they liked expensive
guns
they needed money from their point of
view yeah yeah
so like hey we've got all this stuff we
can't get money really easy they're like
man
we need to rob this bank so i could buy
that new rifle that's
probably exactly what it is that's kind
of shitty dude man [ __ ] we robbed
that bank i'll get that new hk91 if they
came out
the thing that kills me the thing that
kills me about bank robberies
yeah um is that if you plan a bank
robbery for a really long time
and you know you have everything sorted
out and then you do it and you get away
with it and you get away with because i
think one of their prior bank robberies
i think they got away with 1.5 million
stop yeah you have 1.5 million dollars
yeah
two dudes like this in california that
go through their hands just don't do it
anymore
they'd [ __ ] spin that just [ __ ] off
to another country they'll never catch
you
they spent all that [ __ ] on [ __ ] do
it again
getting high doing steroids don't do it
again dating bikini girls
yeah [ __ ] man if i got away with a bank
robbery with 1.5 million dollars i'm set
for life man i'm moving to [ __ ]
bimini or some [ __ ] like they're moving
somewhere where there's not any [ __ ]
expedition treaty those two dudes
[ __ ] those two dudes [ __ ] spit
that [ __ ] quickly i'll never find my ass
holy [ __ ] i don't know why they didn't
just do that because like i said they
did like a couple successful jobs prior
to this
yeah so they got out so then
in june of 95 uh these two dudes
uh did another armored car job this was
a brink's armored car this was in uh
winnetka
uh they ambushed it and this is the one
they actually killed a guard
his name was herman cook and uh they
seriously injured uh
the other one and uh then in may of 1996
they robbed two different branches of
bank of america that was in san fernando
valley
and from these two robberies as i
mentioned earlier they got about 1.5
million dollars and they got away with
it
so uh so they get called i love this
name
the high incident bandits high incident
bandits yeah it's a high incident yeah
which i thought
that sounds like a good band name yeah
it was a big it was a big incident you
said dude what that dude did
they were laughing and i said they were
dating spent the money on dating bikini
girls yeah those california bikini girls
over there i'll [ __ ] muscle beach
before i could
run right through you probably they
could probably spend
1.5 million i'm just saying if it was me
if i had spent all this time and i said
okay i gotta wave like scot-free with
1.5 million dollars like i said i'm
going into [ __ ] hiding you're never
gonna find my ass
i'm gonna live the rest of my life on
that [ __ ] these dudes were bodybuilders
they couldn't hide
they couldn't hide they were
bodybuilding yeah i could but you could
use some of that 1.5 million to get like
facial reconstruction and then like you
look different
that's just not the mentality of these
guys they were high visibility they're
not like master criminals like i am
[Laughter]
yeah i'm a master criminal if you're a
master
i don't think you'd be doing these shows
well no it's like i said if i was if i
if i was a master criminal i'd be like i
wouldn't even be
higher i'd be off in the [ __ ]
french riviera at some place like laying
off yeah
i'd have all the money i ever needed
yeah actually you know i do like kind of
to kind of think about it sometimes
that's why i kind of like not these two
[ __ ] but like i like
um i like big heists where nobody gets
hurt
and you know people just like spend
years and years like i said the you know
like the [ __ ] antwerp diamond heist
and all that kind of [ __ ] like that
fascinated me because those dudes spent
like two [ __ ] years
planning that [ __ ] and they like they
got people in there like his moles like
to work in the place and
they worked there for like two years so
they could get all the inside
information and
they were just like and they didn't hurt
anybody but they got away with like a
billion dollars worth of [ __ ] it's like
it was amazing
yeah we got fan boys in the comments
section that know this case pretty well
like preppers and
and xana xanada knows this this case
real well too
um they weren't gonna stop they they
were they they were adrenaline drunk
junkies yeah they were kind of like just
like what uh prepper says
these are kind of like gambling addicts
yeah they were never gonna stop
uh and no matter how much money they got
their hands on they would spend every
bit of that [ __ ]
that's what they were doing they'd buy
body armor and guns and ammo and spend
it on
drugs and performance-enhancing drugs
and steroids and
probably girls and booze and go right
back to robin banks these guys weren't
going anywhere
see it's like that just seems like so
like i'm not saying that if i wasn't a
master criminal
and i had like a [ __ ] ton of money yeah
i would spend some of it on like nice
food and vacations and stuff like that i
would spend some of it
on booze probably like a lot of booze
but not all of it
you're not a six foot two [ __ ] muscle
man on [ __ ] roids
well clearly i'm glad i'm not hormones
are a hell of a drug
okay um steroids
is an improved version of testosterone
it's an improved hormone
it's more targeted to muscle growth but
it affects the mind
in a way very similar to testosterone
makes you
very hard driving very kind of um
emotional and impos impulsive especially
at the doses
that these guys needed being being as
big as they were
they were taking a lot and you do get a
rush from it
and you get a superman feeling they
didn't care if they were going to get
caught they were just going to go out
you know what i mean that was for
another time they weren't worried about
that at that time no they weren't
they were having fun well plus before
this particular job they took muscle
relaxants
this is a this is a huge power rush for
them yeah well the reason why they're
taking muscle relaxants because when
you're on steroids
sometimes you'll get kind of cramps
you'll get sore real fast
because uh it's kind of like a small
workout becomes kind of like a bigger
more effective workout
it's kind of one of one of the things
that it'll kind of do to you
the muscle relaxants would limber you up
keep you from getting real sore just
running around yeah
you know see that's why i knew this was
going to be a good show that's why i
knew you wanted to do this show because
you know about weightlifting and you
know about all the guns they use so it's
kind of like this is right in your
bailiwick yeah and and the drugs that
they're the kind of drugs that they were
taking
some of those performance-enhancing
drugs you'll get sore
just sitting still for sitting still for
too long
so they say a trend balloon will do that
it'll [ __ ] just make you shredded as
a [ __ ] but if you stay
stay still in longer than about like
definitely they can't drive dude's got
to stop and get out of the car and
stretch his legs and walk around
oh then he gets back in his car and
drive for another 20 30 minutes and he
goes oh i got to get out of the car
[Laughter]
well because your legs are kind of like
cramping up you know
rusty asked what sources are we using uh
mostly like
wikipedia there was some vice [ __ ] there
was a couple of
um documentaries there was one that was
called shootout
there was one that was called 44 minutes
i think uh i watched that as well and
took some notes on that
i watched it happen live i remember
watching it happen live but that was
like a long time ago
blew my [ __ ] mind i couldn't believe
what i was seeing i saw some of the you
know they
they showed like some of the clips and
[ __ ] like that like but like i said i
think you can see the whole thing on
youtube you can get the whole thing
i mean i'm pretty sure it's still on
there yeah yeah
santa said this was such an epic moment
of 90s history i remember
right where i was yeah i remember when
this happened
i mean you know how old was i 97 that
was like like i was 25
25 i was 25. it was 97
yeah i'd have been in boston at the time
no no no it was mississippi yeah i was
in mississippi my first wife yeah
yeah i was remember where i was when i
saw it i might have been at work
yeah i can't remember where i was like i
don't think i sat there and watched the
whole thing but i kept
like glancing over i might have been at
work as well they showed them basically
both die
on live tv yeah and like i said if you
watch the documentaries now which just
show the clips they show at least at
least larry
dying yeah they show larry [ __ ] i
guess he blew his own head off
you can't really tell if he did that or
if he just like kind of [ __ ] up
they say that he committed suicide but
well one of them shot him at the same
time but i don't know if that would have
killed him or just paralyzed
and also i was kind of under the i
thought it might have been an
accident too because he looked like it i
think he got
shot in his hand and knocked the thumb
off or something and then his
his pistol malfunctioned it looked like
he looked in the damn barrel and then
that's what some of the cops on the
documentary were saying too they're like
we weren't entirely sure
like if i think he just like logically
accidentally
blew his own head off or if he meant to
do it i remember
they thought maybe he i think it was an
accident i think it was an accident some
of the cops said that too
sure it looked like an accident to me
well like you said that
he had been hit in the hands i think it
knocked his thumb off and
yeah yeah and he looked at the pistol
and it went off
yeah i think he looked at the pistol and
pulled the trigger to see if it was
still working
and not realizing that he was looking
down the barrel when he pulled the
trigger
he's being shot at well and like i said
as soon as that happened
like uh copped one of the rounds shut
him into
a shotgun i think it got him like in the
spine yeah he's been shot out there
[ __ ]
live rounds going everywhere it happened
so fast i think he got confused
and they were under a lot of adrenaline
and [ __ ] there was like you said they
were on drugs too they were on
performance enhancing drugs
and downers and muscle alaskan relaxants
they tried to
but then they were just going through
the roof yelling at everybody and
swearing at everybody and
some of the [ __ ] that they were saying
was evidently pretty wild some of the
women i'll get into it later
larry i'm using [ __ ] psychological
terror tactics on the cops
[ __ ] calling them all kinds of
[ __ ] and [ __ ] oh yeah that's right
yeah larry esso where in mississippi
i was at that time that i was watching
it or where did i live probably the time
you live
well i don't know either at that time
yeah
never look at the barrel of the loaded
gun says xanada yeah yeah
look like he looked down it looked like
he looked down and maybe pulled the
trigger to see if it was still working
because he thought it didn't work and it
went off it was working because it hit
him in the hand and the
wily coyote shift yeah
well he was under fire and it was
happening real fast does it work blam
huh
he put it kind of under his chin it was
like underneath yeah it wasn't like in
his face
i hadn't seen it in a while i just
remember it was kind of under his chin
yeah i'd have to see it again that's
just kind of how i remembered it
i mean you know he's a [ __ ] back
driver [ __ ]
so you know i'm kind of but yeah they
they weren't real sure like i said
i think some sources say yeah maybe he
committed suicide but i think most the
cops said we couldn't really tell like
we thought maybe it might have been an
accident like he didn't mean to do that
the video that i saw
was kind of from a distance with the
hell it was from the helicopter yeah and
they're trying to zoom in on them it's
not really clear
yeah cause there was a bunch of cop
helicopters and news helicopters like
going around that's why they got the
whole thing on
video it happened real fast fourth throw
down said and then an anvil fell on his
head
yeah which would have been really funny
if that had actually really happened
all right so uh you want to talk about
actually maybe you should get me a new
drink before we start
you want another one of those do you
want an orange um let's do orange this
time
i know you just made the lemonade but
after that we'll kind of get into
the timeline yeah xanada was saying that
they took shots at the choppers too
which yeah they did
and actually the the helicopters because
they had you know kind of more
long-range [ __ ] than the cops had so the
helicopters actually did kind of have to
move out of the way but i just thought
that was so that again very cartoonish
it's like we're just shooting at the
helicopters going over i don't know uh
i wonder when it was broadcast live how
many were rooting for the bad guys
yeah probably some people were i mean
this is like i don't know like i said if
you're gonna rob a bank
just [ __ ] walk in there don't have a
don't have a weapon just a pro tip and
just
don't have a weapon you can lie and say
you have a weapon but don't like cosmic
don't
like [ __ ] shoot up the ceiling like
these [ __ ] did or anything like
that because somebody could get hurt
you know if you have to rob a bank i
don't really i don't have any love for
banks in particular so it's like i'm not
really that worried about it plus like i
said they're insured
but you know so so i'm not really all
that bothered if nobody gets hurt
but these [ __ ] seriously
[ __ ] these dudes yeah xander said i'm
not a fan of bank of america just saying
yeah a lot of people aren't um
i do have uh accounts there but
you know it's just kind of like orange
all right so let's get into
the day yeah everyone's saying screw
bank of america
yeah basically if somebody wants to rob
like it's like i said as long as they
don't hurt anybody if they just walk in
with a note and again give me some
[ __ ] money like i said they're
insured
what do they have like billions and
billions of dollars do not incite people
to cry
even [ __ ] banks alone if you really
want to [ __ ] with the banks [ __ ] get
bitcoin
uh dean says can you ask tom what might
happen if you shot into the rotating
helicopter blade because we were because
xanada was saying that they actually did
shoot at the helicopters that we're
going over because they did
not much nothing would happen not much
no
you can you can do that you can shoot
into those blades you can really
i mean the uh-1 huey and the in the
uh-60 blackhawk
especially the uh-1 took a lot of fire
during vietnam and its career and never
reported any problems even
if you got a small arms fire hitting the
main rotor nothing would happened
yeah it probably it probably just go
through it do a little bit of damage but
that won't that won't bring the
helicopter down
well i would hope not yeah i mean you
would think that yeah
world war one pilots used to shoot their
own propellers they just put deflectors
on the back of the propellers
before they figured it out ah [ __ ]
before they figured out how to put an
interrupter on the machine gun so they
shoot through the propellers
they just put some [ __ ] plug that's
right i remember flat plates in there
i remember like watching a documentary
yeah
[Laughter]
we probably won't die it'll be fine all
right so
uh we're talking about the morning of
february 28th 1997.
now these two dudes uh i guess they had
been a case in this joint
for a couple of months prior to this and
they'd had all these plans and [ __ ] like
that
so this was the bank of america branch
which was at uh 6600
laurel canyon boulevard so
they put on all of their homemade body
armor they got all of their
uh firepower which they had which i'm
sure tom knows uh
all of the yeah they took a weaponry
that they had uh wikipedia says
semi-automatic hk91 several illegally
converted weapons two
neuron co type 56 s rifles fully
automatic norenco type 56
s1 fully automatic bushmaster xl15
dissipator
yes okay it's an hk91
okay which was is a
that's this that was the semi-auto
version the american semi-auto version
of the g3 rifle was a it was a 762
battle rifle um it's pretty good there
was what three aks
three near wrinkles uh yeah yeah
three aks norenko aks which are very
good quality especially for the time
uh some people laugh at chinese [ __ ]
yeah a lot of chinese products sucked
but things that came out of norenko and
polytech company were very good aka
clones
uh the type 56 it was carried in chinese
service for a long time
the deluxe it's a deluxe ak real nice
it wasn't like a european ak though
there was differences in it
they take they took those and they
converted them to full auto and they did
it using
you know full auto bolt carriers uh
redrilled the receivers put in uh put in
the uh
pin kits and all the [ __ ] trigger
parts so it was select fire it was
semi-auto full auto and
and and uh safe so all three
selections all all three positions on
the selector
so they do knew what they were doing the
other one was a um
thing called a dissipator it was made by
bushmaster
it was a
bushmaster was a company that kind of
cloned
cult m16s or ar-15 type stuff it was
mostly the military spec the dissipator
ended up being real famous because of em
that was the one that emel was using
and he had a modified dissipator which
was
basically a occult
ar-15 or m16a2
um rifle instead of 20-inch barrel it
had a 16 inch barrel
and emel put a collapsible stock on it i
don't think
i don't think the original had had the
collapsible
stock on it i think the original had a
fixed stock
um and one of the things that what is it
was of note of emel's dissipator
is that he took the a2 handguards off of
it and put
colt m16a1 triangular m16 handguards on
it looked cool as [ __ ] i got a picture
of one right here
uh then he took the flash suppressor off
and put
um put a he put a muzzle break on there
and it was had three holes it was a
three hole muzzle brake
kind of like what you'd see on an amd65
um i'm gonna show you a picture of a
of an ammo dissipator okay
okay that's what m16a1 style handguard
is on there you can see the lights on
yeah that's pretty much what emel had
except his
had a different muzzle on it xanada also
said uh he had a 50 or 100 round drum on
the dissipator too i thought yeah i
thought he did as well yeah i thought it
was 100 rounds right yeah it was a
hundred man it's called a c
mag and it was a pretty easy to get and
kind of a famous
100 round drum magazine that you could
get back in the 90s
that was notoriously unreliable just a
piece of [ __ ]
and you see him you see it you see it
doing several malfunctions during the
shoot up
he just clears the jabs and keeps on
going not really a good uh
magazine they make a lot better ones now
really you don't want anything more than
on an ar-15 really you they have some
60 rounders out there it looks like two
30 round magazines
together um i think it's a german
company that makes it
and that's a lot more compact and a lot
more reliable
you know what i mean not a big
difference between 60 and 100 if you
want if you want a bunch of ammo
if you if you want a big capacity get
that 60 rounder
a lot smaller yeah that's that [ __ ]
100 runner was [ __ ] ungainly
nasty rattle make it make a bunch of
noise
cheap plastic you know and it didn't it
jammed
matter of fact i think that kid that
dressed up like the joker and shot up
the inside of the [ __ ]
uh theater remember that remember that
douche bag
who was that was that adam lanza i think
that's what no no adam lanza was one
that shot the little kids
um at his mom there's so many i can't
douche bag with the orange hair thought
he was the joker anyway i think he had
that same magazine
and it jammed what was up there on stage
and i think they [ __ ]
jumped his ass during that jam where he
threw it down and picked up
started shooting with a pistol something
like that james holmes
yeah those names james i guess so yeah
those big large capacity magazines like
that they tend to suck
you can take that from me i'm an ex army
machine gunner m60 and m249 and all that
[ __ ] even bell-fed weapons they're
a lot half the time they're shot to [ __ ]
they're not real reliable
well you're just like trying to put all
that [ __ ] through there it's like too
much man you gotta like [ __ ]
you know well it's gone through so many
hands by the time you've got it and how
old is this thing and
a lot of [ __ ] grimy ass sandy [ __ ]
belts
ammunition have gone through it just
chewed everything up the feed paws on
the top do the feed tray covers and just
there things are just kind of worn out
you know
bell-fed weapons are [ __ ] finicky and
then anything
large capacity magazine above 30 rounds
tends to be pretty
finicky you know
yeah i'm going to say okay so
well like i said i'm never sure when
you're done talking because sometimes
you stop talking and then i start
talking and then you start talking so
that's how i like it all right so uh
these two [ __ ] also
had filled up a jar with gasoline and i
guess it was in the back seat i guess
what they were planning on doing was
that
if they got away or whatever they're
gonna blow the car up and like to
destroy evidence
i'm assuming that that's what they were
doing so
larry uh as we mentioned earlier they
had made most of their own uh body armor
so larry had about 40 pounds of
equipment on not just body armor but
other things too
he had a bulletproof vest uh he had a
groin guard uh he had a
bunch he had another like load bearing
vest with a bunch of like uh military
canteen pouches for ammunition storage
and uh all the homemade body armor uh
that he created from spare vests
and this was covering his shin thighs
and forearms so he was pretty much
covered from like neck to ankle his head
was still
you know he just had a [ __ ] uh you
know ski mask on or whatever so he
didn't have any like [ __ ] on his head
but then you know the it kind of came
where yes if somebody had got him in the
head and the cops did actually try to do
that
but he they were laying down so much
fire that they couldn't really get a
good shot at him
hold on prepper asked a good question um
there's a uh prepper's talking about he
wanted to know if there was a three pin
modification on the on
on the dissipator to get full auto
trigger parts in it
so i i actually don't know i know that
he did that to the
to the ak the aks they had he had him
he did a good job converting them you
can see it there's a photograph
of emel's um dissipator sitting there on
the ground
i i don't remember if there's enough
detail if you could see the pins or not
he might have just like you said made a
lightning link
they're easy to make you can make one
out of a coat hanger
coat hanger wire if you know what you're
doing you got to tune it right
it's another way to do it out of two
pieces of sheet metal
um lightning links have been around
forever
um but as somebody that has a lot of
experience with the ar
platform full auto is not the way to go
delta force really doesn't use it
neither does
sf a good light semi-auto trigger like a
ke arms trigger with a real short
[ __ ] release on it something you can
go
there's just a lot more control a lot
more accuracy
full auto is really good in the movies
and it scares the [ __ ] out of people
that aren't really used to it
you know to kind of create havoc on
people but it's just a waste of [ __ ]
ammo really i think that's what they
were trying to do yeah they were just
trying to create chaos they're trying to
create chaos because they weren't aiming
at people necessarily it's real
intimidating to people who aren't
used to being shot at by it you know but
[ __ ] if you're in the army for a long
time you're just being shot at by
[ __ ] f full auto weapons firing
blanks over and over that sound over and
over and over again
it's just so routine nobody gives a [ __ ]
if you you know but the ar-15 and the
in the ak-47 are best as carbines or
rifles in semi-auto that's really where
your best troops who are effective
they're using
using them as semi-auto carbines you
know they're fast shooters and accurate
but it's semi-auto you don't need full
auto full auto is kind of
full auto is trying to compensate for
[ __ ] lack of training
and they're also trying to compensate
for a shitty trick
semi-auto trigger pull you can't pull
that hard trigger fast and
it's not very accurate so you flip it
over to full auto and just hold it down
and let four or five of them
out of there and hope that you hit if
you just put a good semi-auto trigger in
there you don't have to do that you can
just hit with the first round
that's you know that's you know that's a
it's a military trigger is [ __ ] real
hard
that's why there's a full auto setting
okay good
all right so uh so like i said uh larry
had
you know body armor pretty much neck to
ankle however
uh emile just had a bulletproof vest on
although he did kind of augment it he
had like these metal
plates like trauma plates that he put
kind of like over the heart and you know
the gut
area so like in case he got hit there
you know it wouldn't but he didn't have
anything on his legs or anything so now
this is where i was thinking
that they got this idea from heat
because both of them
they had a watch and they synchronized
their watches just like all like master
criminals do
and they sewed the watch onto their
gloves yeah like so they could and i'm
pretty sure they got that idea from heat
yeah right i mean i don't know i haven't
seen heat once i saw i saw him laying
there in a photograph of that dab
watch soda on the back of that leather
military work glove really
and i was like man they went through all
the trouble to do that
and i was just kind of wondering why but
you know maybe they thought
maybe they thought it was justified i
don't know they might have had some or
they just found it
they thought it was cool i guess yeah
maybe i was
in the era we used to do that kind of
[ __ ] we were in service in the 90s
it was in the era where you couldn't
really get a wide variety of really good
military or para military equipment
so when we were in the army we were
doing things like
taking old bdu shirts and cutting the
pockets off of them and sewing those
pockets onto the shoulder areas of our
field bdus
you can see that in predator one they
have extra bdu pockets on there
it's because we were doing that and we
learned that that that was
80s we learned that from the generation
before us was sewing extra pockets on
things and
making little [ __ ] range card books
out of glowing tape and [ __ ] 100 mile
an hour tape and we just we made our own
things
take a dive flashlight and cover it and
[ __ ] rubber and [ __ ] tape and
tape that underneath an ar-15 or an m16
big old dive light with an ir cover on
it you know we
but now you can buy all that [ __ ]
because there's a huge aftermarket
but we didn't have that back then yeah
so it was kind of like a sign of a
professional if you could
fabricate your own equipment and we did
it a lot
i mean it's talking about during time
when delta force dudes [ __ ] wore
[ __ ] hockey helmets and [ __ ]
a lot of people don't know that
[ __ ] delta force didn't wear
k-pop wear hockey helmet
thank you maddie p 3400 sent us a
super chat and said can tom be my life
coach
i'm having a problem coaching my own
life dude
are you really yes it seems like it
seems like it
yeah xanada was just talking about the
eight-minute rule yeah i was just gonna
about to get into that so yeah so
so they had all this stuff they had the
watches sewn on there like i said i'm
pretty sure they got that idea from pete
i could be totally wrong about that but
that's
that's what i thought uh as i mentioned
before they took uh phenobarbital
uh before i guess emile had a
prescription for it
so they took that they thought it would
like you know calm them down or they
you know keep them from getting sore
while they were running around like you
said
so they pull up at the bank uh about
9 17 a.m and at this point they
synchronize their watches like i said
and they set their alarms for eight
minutes they had an eight minute rule
because this because of prior research
um i guess they had been monitoring
police scanners
uh and similar kind of crimes to what
they were planning on doing
and they thought that it would take the
police eight minutes to respond which to
me
seems like kind of a long time you know
what i mean and
indeed that's ended that's how it ended
up happening because i'm like eight
minutes i'm like i'm pretty sure they'd
get there before eight minutes
but that's for whatever reason that's
what they thought we're like we're gonna
be in and out in eight minutes before
then the cops won't even get here
so that's what they thought so
but the two of them in all of their
[ __ ] gear right it's not like they
were trying to be like inconspicuous or
anything they had all their body armor
on that ski masks on they had everything
they walk into the bank at 9 17 in the
morning they had been
parked there like prior to the bank
opening and then just like
only a few minutes after hoping they
walked in and
as soon as they walked in there happened
to be two
lapd cops um that were driving down
laurel canyon road in a patrol car
and saw them and we're like hey looks
like some [ __ ] about to rob a
bank
and so they called it in
uh so yeah eight minutes not so much
because they got seen pretty much the
minute they walked in the door
so you know so uh yeah robbery in
progress they called that in
now larry and emil walk into the bank uh
and they there was like somebody that
was using the atm
um near the entrance i guess it was one
of those because you know bank of
america has an atm like on the front
and i guess it was somebody that was
using that and so they forced that
person
to go into the bank and then made them
lay on the floor
now at this point there's a security
guard inside the bank
like most banks have and uh he saw
the kind of uh you know little scuffle
out there where they were forcing this
person inside the bank
so the security guard also radioed to
his partner who was sitting out in the
car
out in the parking lot and they also
called the police so like i said
you know the i don't know this eight
minutes thing
you know is off that's a wildly
i mean it's la for [ __ ] sake and
you're walking into a bank
with weapons and body armor and
everything like do you think no one's
gonna see you it's like the daytime and
people are like walking past
i think um part of the tactic was just
to be so
menacing and so intimidating that people
would just be stunned and be afraid to
respond which
i think is i think it worked well you
got a little while these dudes were huge
yeah they were [ __ ] big big [ __ ]
dudes on roid range the [ __ ]
full body armor they took a bunch of
um ballistic vests i think it was just
rated against pistol ammo
cut them up and made shin guards and die
guards well larry did and neil didn't
have that
he just had the the vest with like uh
trauma plates inside
the plates they don't have like taped up
in there you know so
they were at least at least larry was
impervious
he'd been shot a [ __ ] ton of times and
not hurt
yeah i mean i think what what was it i
think did he
end up getting shot like one of them was
shot like 29 times well he got shot it
might have been
and then he shot himself yeah emily got
shot the pieces
through the legs through his legs they
were shooting at him underneath the car
yes he was hiding on this side of the
car they were shooting underneath but
we're getting ahead of ourselves
they'd run in and just go get out start
[ __ ] get out everybody and they were
real rude to everybody yeah
this is the [ __ ] come here though
yeah they were they were big into
calling people [ __ ] and stuff like
that and they were
big into intimidating people and it's
just this big [ __ ]
in full body armor with full auto
weapons and if you didn't have the money
he'd shoot the money in front of him
they weren't afraid of
shooting in front of people well
basically as soon as they walked in
they were shooting into the ceiling like
automatic yeah uh fire into the ceiling
yeah which their thinking is is they
were gonna go in there like gangbusters
and just
intimidate the [ __ ] out of people well
i'm pretty sure the bank robberies
they've done before this is how they had
done it and it was like like i said an
intimidation time yeah because everyone
i mean nobody wants to get shot right so
they're just kind of like okay whatever
take the [ __ ] out and uh
the witnesses said that [ __ ] you know
like they want to do that he grabbed he
goes where's the money you know and they
just said he was just seething with
anger
it was like just seething with [ __ ]
rage and anger
and when he when he saw that that wasn't
a lot of money he just took the ak and
just [ __ ] unloaded a magazine into
the [ __ ]
yeah we'll get into that yeah yeah and
they were just
terrified you know what i mean could
that they would shoot you in a heartbeat
and that's the way these guys wanted it
because if you can keep it if you can
keep a crowd of people just
totally terrified chances are you're not
gonna have to kill any of them that's
their thinking
well yeah i'm pretty sure that that's
what they're i'm not saying that's you
know
good i'm not saying that like that was
like it's just a tactic yeah but that
was the tactic that they used
um they didn't really go in planning to
kill anybody i don't think they would
have necessarily cared if they killed
anybody but
they were trying to minimize it they
were trying to minimize yeah they just
went in there and they just like were
going in big like for intimidation i
think inside the bank
there were about 30 people and that
includes the people that work there and
the
and the customers as well yeah they went
in there they wanted you to just roll
over immediately
and according to some of the sources
that i heard everything kind of had
everything kind of had a sexual tone to
it you know
you're a [ __ ] roll over [ __ ] homos
you [ __ ] blah blah blah blah
um just anything to get you to submit to
the to their [ __ ]
ultra masculine dominant power you a hoe
that that was the thing you know i don't
care who you are dude
compared to me you're a hoe that was
their whole attitude
evidently that's how they spoke to the
cops when they were exchanging fire
yeah it's psychological psychological
warfare
yeah yeah so yeah so they get everybody
to kind of lay down on the floor right
and then they um larry he shoots open
um you know the bulletproof there's like
a door you know what i mean like where
the tellers are
so he shoots that open because it's
bulletproof but not for
the rounds that they had you know it's
only like a little bit bulletproof
well pistols and rifles there's a big
difference in energy
they're carrying intermediate rifle
rifle rounds in
assault rifles 16 inch barrel minimum
stuff
you need a different grade of armor to
protect against that
yeah pistols are easy to protect against
there's not
not not nearly as much energy in a
pistol round
yeah yeah so that's what so they shot
through that
like i said the door that went back to
where the tellers were and where the
vault was
so then they find uh john villagrana who
was the assistant manager
and they forced him to open up the vault
so he opens the vault because he didn't
want to get shot obviously and he starts
filling up their
bag but i guess the robbers
they thought that they were going to get
750 000 from this heist
that's what they were planning on
however
um what they didn't count on was that i
guess
the bank's delivery schedule had changed
which the robbers did not know and they
actually hadn't gotten their delivery of
cash yet
that day and i'm not even sure if it was
coming that day
so there wasn't as much money in the
vault as they were expecting and this
made them very very angry
okay now grantor's hammer veteran police
officer
says 99 of the people would just [ __ ]
their pants and freeze
if a guy's walking to a bank carrying
ars and wearing masks
yeah that's that's my experience also
and you there's
plenty of videos with that the more
intimidating the guys are
the more menacing and professional they
look the faster people submit to them
this is the way it is very hard to be a
bad [ __ ] in front of [ __ ]
two huge [ __ ] just loaded for
well like i said you don't want to get
shot because obviously it really seemed
like this
these dudes looked like they hated you
and they were seething with [ __ ]
hatred
and i feel like if somebody had like
tried to be a hero and like run at them
they probably would have shot them yeah
i mean it yes we're saying that it
seemed like they were trying to just do
intimidation and they weren't aiming at
anybody specifically they were just
aiming to the ceiling
it was just a warning if somebody had
tried to
they'd have killed you resist against
them i think they would have killed i
don't really think they cared all that
much
so so like i said they thought they were
gonna get 750 grand
from this uh but that was not uh the
case
because the delivery schedule was
different uh than what they had
anticipated so there wasn't as much in
the vault
so larry got super [ __ ] aggro
about this uh news and then he
fired a full uh drum magazine 75 rounds
into the bank safe yeah and uh destroyed
most of what was left of the money i
missed out
what he got yeah uh what they got i
think they ended up just getting a
little over three hundred thousand which
holy [ __ ] man i could live the rest of
my [ __ ] life up 300 000
but okay no you could but it wasn't well
i'm just saying spend that real quick
no you wouldn't i would hide that from
you because you'd be like
hey let's buy this hey let's buy no i'm
keeping him
oh [ __ ] oh it's wig time it's way time
level one i didn't feel like doing a wig
today because i was like i did well i
did i recorded some [ __ ] earlier and i
so i didn't want to like wear a wig
because
it's a whole thing if i wear a wig you
have to wear a wig cap
because i have hair he does not
i'm gonna put my [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
really sexual dinosaur
now i'm carrot top i'm not a sexual
dinosaur
oh my god that was that was a um see
there's a sexual tyrannosaurus out there
but then there's also just sexual
dinosaurs it's just a throwback to
another error
can i be a sexual stegosaurus you need
to be whatever you want to be
okay awesome that was that was something
i hadn't picked up on that it was a 75
round drum
the witness just said he just unloaded
the magazine into the vault
75-round drum and shot all the cash up
and destroyed it yeah i thought it was a
30 rounder
because he was mad yeah prepper knows
you're talking about that's a 75 round
rpk magazine
coming out of china that was a good
magazine very reliable
that was from the rpk squad automatic
weapon it'll go into an ak
yeah okay but so the fact that so like i
said they weren't
like some of the [ __ ] they seemed like
they had some plans and whatnot
but then it just seemed like they got
mad and they just like lost control of
the situation
yeah you know what i mean didn't go
according to plan it didn't go the way
they thought it was going to go
and they didn't have a plan b obviously
um those roids were [ __ ] with them
too yeah at roy
yeah but see like i said if you're gonna
do [ __ ] like this you gotta have your
[ __ ] together have a plan b
have a plan c and a plan d i mean that's
what i would do
but no they were just kind of like yeah
we don't have like three quarters of a
million dollars in there we only have
three hundred thousand
and he was like [ __ ] that one he's just
like [ __ ] unloaded and he lost it
kind of like that wasn't money
that's what i mean it's like [ __ ] yes
300 thousand dollars isn't as good as
750 thousand dollars obviously that's
almost 300 [ __ ] thousand dollars it's
almost half of it yeah
just take it and go yeah jesus christ
you can do another one later
he was not he was that trend bologna
sandwich was [ __ ] him
trampoline yeah he didn't even have a
driver
right yeah i would like to i would like
to see exactly
what steroids it was that they were on
but there's definitely some hormonal
imbalance going on the whole
seething with [ __ ] hatred and anger
and having to take
downers and relaxants to do it and yeah
they were [ __ ] loaded
and then they were amped up just because
of the situation because like i said
if they hadn't done that they might have
got away with the [ __ ]
but they just maybe not because like i
said the comps came much earlier than
they were anticipating
but if they hadn't just like lost their
[ __ ] and said hey i'm going to shoot up
all the money it's like just take the
money and get the [ __ ] out
you know what i mean it's like these two
dudes just all that male
male pms dinosaur pms yeah
and that dinosaur pms
somebody please make a gift out of that
moment
my muscles they're locking up on me
i need a massage i'm pretty sure that's
exactly what happened
yeah dudes are ridiculous yeah dudes are
ridiculous
did we get we got into that like a
little bit on the side traction these
[ __ ] didn't have the money
i'm [ __ ] losing it you guys are ready
i love it i love it and his buddy should
have said dude that's half of it though
[ __ ] half you know not good enough yeah
yeah
yeah yeah it was like that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
[ __ ] man this and this is the point
where it went off the rails yeah like
you know what i mean it's like you know
obviously it went off the rails when
they first decided to do in the first
place but this was definitely the place
where it went off the rails
so so he has like over 300 000
i think it was 303 000 or something like
that so he has that in his [ __ ] bag
not enough so he shoots up all the rest
of the money in the vault which i guess
was just a little penny annie [ __ ]
and then he decides that he's gonna try
and get into the atm
so he says to the branch manager he's
like hey i need to get into the atm but
the branch manager
he said yeah i can't get that because
bank of america changed their policies i
used to be able to get in there but now
i can't
so obviously so basically
so larry is just like denied and so
he locks everybody that was in the bank
he locks them all
in the vault um
and not only that this is like a wah
wah moment not only do you get 303
thousand dollars but somebody also put a
[ __ ] die pack in there
so the [ __ ] [ __ ] blew up and they
couldn't use it anyway even if they had
gotten away but they didn't so it's like
it doesn't really matter but yeah so
they
somebody gotta put some dye packs in
there and uh it exploded so
so like i said the the picture that i
posted on instagram
was like a you know a bundle of the
money that was kind of [ __ ] up and had
like red dial over it
yeah that's what happened so they
wouldn't have been able to use it
anybody so
good job good job xanada said he saw one
guy describe it as them going to war
within los
angeles yeah that's what it looked like
they kind of lost though i have to say
you know yeah
well and then santa go what was the
actual problem though they had hate in
them it seemed like they just wanted to
shoot at
it it was uh hormones man it was a lot
of [ __ ]
they wanted money they were on all those
[ __ ] roids
they were pissed off they were trying to
be as intimidating as possible um
they were kind of spooked also you would
say that you know because you're they're
doing a robbery
so they're reacting to it with a bunch
of [ __ ] anxiety
which ends up being hatred especially
when the cops show up
they evidently hated the government of
california
and they hated [ __ ] the lapd
most people say that they hated the lapd
yes xena said there was definitely a
hormone factor yeah
testosterone it's a hell of a drug and
all the other [ __ ] they were taking it's
all that other [ __ ] too
steroids are modified improved
testosterone
they'll do [ __ ] to your mind the
testosterone won't even dream of
most people [ __ ] can control it
though they what is it what you do
oh yeah yeah it's just like sticking out
but it's like cracking up because i keep
i see it in the like the moment
i'm just like laughing somebody said
something that she was [ __ ] funny
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god
all right [ __ ] danny says hey tom if
they were wearing steel-toed boots with
the pull
bullets at patrick yes dude yes
rifle pistol rounds go right through
steel it's certain
most of these at combat ranges pistol
round will go through something like a
steel-toed boot come on man
yeah yeah so at this point like i said
all the shit's going on in the bank like
i said the cops have
i mean they had called it in um but it
takes like a couple minutes for
uh the backups to get there so the first
responding officers
um they were there but they heard
gunfire from inside the bank
oh and then what captain blairdo said
some [ __ ] is [ __ ] funny as [ __ ] he
says
watch out for a sexual cambrian
explosion
not
run around on available camera i know
but it was just it doesn't matter but
it's still funny
yeah i'm just i'm i'm well actually well
well
actually i don't want to be i don't want
to be that guy you know what i'm saying
i don't want to be that guy
uh but yeah so so yeah so they hear all
the gunfire so they call in
for uh additional units and then they
jump behind their patrol cars you know
to take cover like they normally would
um and they you know train the weapons
on the bank doors
like i said as they usually would oh
it's pokey yeah pokey has come in i
wondered where you were
you've been sleeping all day she's
jumping up on the [ __ ] chair
all right so uh so the bank rappers are
still inside the bank at this point
um you know shooting up please don't
jump up on the she looks like she's
trying to do it she she tried to jump up
earlier and she landed right on the
mouse pad and she went and she like
[ __ ] came right off the desk didn't
you pookie
i didn't laugh at you though because
that would be mean i know how you do
so uh more patrols more detective units
showed up and they basically like
surrounded the bank so they had like
cops at all four corners um
and this is only like a few minutes
later i think it's 9 24 am at this point
so 9 24 am which like i said i think how
about
so they got there at 9 17 and that was
like three so this is seven minutes
it's still inside their eight minute
window obviously they
didn't plan for this so larry comes out
through one of the doorways and he sees
a cop car
about 200 feet away and started shooting
at it
now at this point uh he wounds seven
officers
and three civilians like i said nobody
like spoiler alert nobody got killed
except for the robbers but a lot of
people got shot up
or he kind of [ __ ] with some people
inside the bank like [ __ ] whacked him
with
uh you know the gun butts and [ __ ] like
that um but nobody
died like the cops didn't die so he
opens fire at the cars
and the uh and civilians he
uh at this point also fires at the
police helicopter
uh which was flying overhead and it had
to kind of
back off a little bit then he goes back
inside
uh for a couple of minutes and then he
comes back out
and then a meal goes out the other x
like on the other side of the building
so both of them come out like opposite
sides of the building
now at this point is probably where like
the main
shootout starts to happen yeah it's also
where the whole thing becomes a cluster
[ __ ] and starts to
starts to fall yeah it's kind of like
the two guys
stopped communicating with each other
and
i don't understand what kind of
cockamamie plan they put together
to get out of this place but the tactics
that they used were just
[ __ ] up like i'mma walk alongside the
car and lay down
fire while the car gets away somehow i'm
not gonna get into the car until the car
shot up that didn't make any sense to me
yeah
just all kinds of weird [ __ ] that they
were doing and that car was shot up
anyway
then they tried to steal a couple of
cars and that didn't work out
and then they separated for some ungodly
reason
why the hell would they separate you go
that way i'll go this way we'll [ __ ]
bring him
no dude once that once a helicopter sees
you it's over
you can't run from a helicopter i mean
there had to be some point where they
knew
that they weren't going to get out of
there a helicopter ever gets on your ass
really the
the only thing you can do is just go
battle of stalingrad
which is get down open a manhole cover
and get down into the sewer
that's that's really the only way you
get down to that sewer system not many
men brave enough to get down into the
sewer system but if you get out of the
city like they'll shoot out some cops so
it's like i'm not wading through [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's pitch dark well that too and uh but
you see
they would they should have like i said
had a plan b or plan c you would have
like flashlights and all kind of [ __ ]
gas masks for that eventuality but no
they did not do that and it the
subterranean system opens up into big
things there's greats there's places
where you'll
you'll have to submerge yourself and be
in deep water you don't really know
where you're going
and and you can't go into that situation
blind you have to go into that knowing
how
your sewer system is built and what it
all looks like in there and what what
what what's the general layout in the
plan of the place you know
and whether or not a human can traverse
it but really the only way to disappear
in a city if a helicopter is on your
asses to get this up
is to get into the uh the super pursuer
yeah i mean like i said that cold wars
were fought in sewers it's possible
and the cops will not follow you down
into a sewer they're not trained or
equipped for it
it's too much because what are they
gonna do go on that sewer for all they
know you're sitting there
in the darkness just with the rifle
sights trying to write on them waiting
for them to come down yeah cause they
don't want their people to get killed
either so it's kind of like they'll wait
you out
right and then they'll say well we lost
him he'll he'll re-emerge later we'll
catch him again
uh but they might send some swat team
guys and some lights and [ __ ]
but by then you'd be you'd be long gone
but they would assume that you went into
the darkness and stayed right there
near the entrance and would be waiting
for them because that would be the
easiest thing to do
because what what kind of guys has the
balls to just go into the damn
unknown into the total darkness you
might get eaten by sewer alligators you
don't know
well the water could be over your head
that too okay
you got a pipe and there might be that
much air in the top of it and you're
down there
going through the pipe trying to suck
air over the top you know and then it's
getting it's getting shallower and
shallower and shallower then
you're like oh well i guess i'll just
swim off into the darkness of this pipe
and hope that it opens up no it might be
a half a mile
okay so you must you really have to want
to get you have to really
want to get away yeah and like i said
you have to have kind of planned for
that eventuality which
it seems like these dudes didn't they
didn't plan for anything like that no
um you know but i mean i don't know i
i just kind of feel like if you're gonna
do something of this magnitude
you should have a couple of alternate
plans i'm just saying i i mean i i
would think it's like hey if this goes
sideways let's do this other thing
if you're gonna you know if you're gonna
spend months planning this [ __ ] might as
well
so yeah so at this point uh larry and
the mailers starting uh
shooting at the cops and uh shooting
into the cop cars
that were uh in front of the bank now at
this point the cops
you know they have standard you know cop
[ __ ] uh they have
uh their berettas they have their smith
and wessons they have their
12-gauge shotguns and they started
shooting back at them
but even if they hit the dudes it wasn't
really penetrating the body armor
because like i said not only
you know did they not have uh as much
firepower but they also were kind of far
away
yeah this is during this phase is the
one where emil or m will depend on how
you want to say his name i've heard it
pronounced both ways
was running around back and forth
returning kind of like a suppressive
fire
back on the lapd and most of the
witnesses say he was saying
get your heads down stop looking at me
don't you look at me
you know don't you look at me yeah yeah
yeah and then that sounds real stable
yeah
don't look at me get your head down what
are you looking at don't look at me and
he's shooting at him
and then like uh he got shot one time
in in the back by a policeman
with a nine millimeter but it just his
armor absorbed and he turned around and
called him all kinds of [ __ ]
and started shooting that and shoot him
and i think he hit that guy but he
was able to make it out of there if he
zeroed in on you he was going to call
you a [ __ ]
according to the witnesses that was his
big thing he [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that was his name he was he was
like i said i don't know why i would
be bothered by that but okay that was
that was his sexual intimidation
thing you know all right whatever yeah
[Laughter]
that was just his uh personality you
know he was mad
uh he's mad [ __ ] just you know mad
and also
man he's stupid
all them down steroids and he just
[ __ ] hated god they hated the lapd
people that knew him said they just
hated the cops but but well they're
getting in the way of all our bank
robberies
but it was evidently focused in not just
cops in general it was the lapd
they hated the lapd i mean i'm not a big
fan of the lapd
either like i don't think anybody is but
this is kind of like a whole
other level of hatred against lapd
you know what i mean well it's just like
xanada said the witnesses said it was
like they went to war with l.a yeah yeah
yeah that matches up with uh
people that knew him said that they were
kind of like they just hated that place
yeah yeah well you know so
at this point like i said they're still
like they're trading gunfire like the
cops are kind of like
realizing that they're uh outgunned i
suppose
um and as i said this whole shootout
lasted what about 45 44 or 45 minutes
so about 10-15 minutes into the [ __ ] um
a cop comes over the radio and says that
the other officers don't
uh stop like if they get in the getaway
vehicle don't stop them because they've
got automatic weapons
and they'll just like [ __ ] terry to
shreds so like don't
attempt to engage them you know in that
way
now at this point too a bunch of
officers had been pinned down
uh because the dudes were just kind of
like just spraying [ __ ] uh bullets
everywhere
and uh you know so the cops were kind of
trying to get a head shot
on some of the dudes but they couldn't
really do it just because you know there
was so much [ __ ]
uh automatic gunfire coming from
everywhere
um at this point a bunch of cops got the
idea i guess it was a gun store
uh just like a block or two away so they
all ran over there and they're like hey
can we borrow some of your [ __ ] thanks
so uh they actually borrowed i think it
was five uh ar-15s
from a gun store and the gun store was
like yeah man just take it
whatever this is the granter's [ __ ]
comment the ex-cop
where is it in the comment section uh i
can't see it maybe i'm behind
yeah yeah sheila anne said i remember
the cops going to the gun store
that's like so [ __ ] funny to me was
they had called swat by this point i'm
pretty sure
but swat wasn't gonna get there yet
because swat team had all the [ __ ] that
the
that the shooters had but the comps just
didn't have that
stuff so they were kind of like well
just to hold us off we're gonna run down
to this [ __ ] gun store
and they cut like a bunch of air ar-15
so they can [ __ ] up fighting
just like really funny so like i said
the guy at the gun store was just kind
of like yeah man just take the [ __ ]
whatever
so uh at this point so there's uh two
locations which were
kind of uh you know on the north parking
lot
and this is where the most of the
officers were taking cover
now at this point they think that
larry got shot um
either larry his person or the rifle
that he was holding
got shot with a handgun now larry
i guess um he was still like shooting at
everybody and he was kind of um
taking cover near uh there were like
some cars that were like four cars like
parked
near the north wall of the bank so he
was kind of trying to take cover over
there but the cops were shooting at him
they're pretty sure they hit him at this
point and or they hit his
uh his gun right now
there was also um yeah
i don't know so one one of the locations
uh was a del taco
which was uh only about 350 feet from
where larry was
and so there was a bunch of cops like
taking cover over there
so at this point one of the officers
officer uh zielenski i think his name
was
um he was shooting at larry from the del
taco
right and uh he thinks that he hit him
at least one time
uh he either hit his person or he hit
the gun they're not really sure um so
the
other location where some of the
officers were was there was a house at
6641 agnes avenue and a bunch of the
cops were kind of in the backyard there
and i think there was like a cinderblock
wall
and they were kind of like shooting at
them from behind that
um and at that point i think from that
uh
vantage point too i think they might
have hit uh larry as well like i said
there was so much
gunfire going on there was so much chaos
that they weren't really sure
like who got shot when you know what i'm
saying like where the [ __ ] came from
because it was just like so much [ __ ]
going on so
at this point there was another there
was a detective
detective bancroft um he was shooting at
the
at larry and there was another detective
named detective harley who was also
shooting at him
they were only about 50 feet away from
him now at this point
uh emile uh he backs their car
which was a chevy celebrity they had
parked in a handicapped space because
they weren't big enough [ __ ] it's
like yeah we are
also going to park this [ __ ] they're
going to awesome
because they just had to like put the
cherry on top of the dickishness
we'll just park in the handicapped spot
they're parked in that they had parked
in the hattie guys
because it's closer we're going to rob
the [ __ ] you know
yeah yeah they're not worried about that
ticket i guess not
yeah preppers laughing so i laughed at
that too i know it's [ __ ] up but i
laughed at it also
so uh so he backs the car out of the
handicapped space
and parked in the north parking lot and
at this point uh while he was doing that
larry uh got shot in the left
wrist now this they're pretty sure that
that's where he got shot because like
the helicopter got the footage of it
like you said you saw that
and uh and i saw it as well and he
looked like he was just like oh [ __ ]
like he got
[ __ ] shot you know what i mean yeah
react to it he was shooting an ak
ak had a drum on it he was having a
problem engaging some guys for some
reason he just threw the ak
i think it jammed yeah but i don't know
why he couldn't clear it
he couldn't clear it i guess well that's
what like i was watching the documentary
yeah that's the documentary the cops
said those are like very easy to clear
we don't really know why he couldn't
figure out i think they were panicking
yeah probably just through the ak and
it wasn't empty he hadn't emptied that
whole drum
yeah pulled out a pistol and he's
engaged in some guys across the street
he's done yeah
he said it's a stoke pipe jam that's
what it is it's very common yeah
i saw the [ __ ] happen i saw the picture
of the damn weapon laying there i was
like why didn't you just clear that
they don't they don't have formalized
training that's part of the deal they
don't they're not
soldiers their first problem they did
train on the range and they did stuff
but
you're not talking about soldiers okay
this is pure
balls uh adrenaline
and steroids and willpower
not so much you know [ __ ]
professional finesse you know
professional fanatics they never would
have done a mission like this this is a
wild-ass mission
somebody hasn't really thought it
through or thought any back in
in any contingencies okay
armed takeover robberies are high risk
they're not profitable in the long run
you eventually go get caught or killed
that's not how you want if you're going
to steal money that's not how you do it
you want to take less risk something
that you can do over a long period of
time
like some kind of real estate scam if
you're [ __ ] smart you know what i
mean
which is what larry was doing to start
with so why didn't he just stick with
that yeah
much less chance of you getting your
face shut off yeah and if you get
caught the chances you do a really hard
time over there a lot less yeah because
it's not violent crime you're gonna go
under a [ __ ] white collar like i said
just be like a computer hacker yeah
something like that
you gotta do some shillings somebody's
not a [ __ ] physical threat to other
people they're not gonna [ __ ] really
treat you the same way
you're running around shooting a [ __ ]
place up fighting the [ __ ] cops
they're gonna kill you
well yeah okay what happened and
probably rightfully so i mean just a
[ __ ] menace to society yeah
uh society at large you can kill people
just by accident
and that's the thing that amazes me
about this [ __ ] that no one was killed
by accident because there was so much
[ __ ] like [ __ ]
automatic fire like going everywhere
like in all directions and there were
houses if you see like the maps there's
houses and other
businesses and [ __ ] like all around
there yeah so i see him from the
helicopter shot he [ __ ] dumps the ak
which is a good weapon all right and
takes it and picks
and it pulls out of looks like a nine
millimeter semi-auto pistol
which is a terrible weapon that's a huge
step down
civilians that don't have any experience
the difference between a military style
fighting rifle and a military style
fighting pistol
are vast it's a huge step down
pistols are not to be used in combat
they're be used usually to get yourself
out of combat
you're shooting in one direction and
running in another and you're running
for a rifle or you're running for
[ __ ] cover to get away from a dude
it's not a real weapon it's a temporary
emergency tool
to get yourself out of a jam so i'm
gonna throw the good weapon away and
use this little [ __ ] pistol to back
myself up against an army of cops with
pistols
so you're gonna throw away your
advantage it just didn't make it i think
he just freaked out because he couldn't
get i mean
like i said it was a stove pipe jam
which is a pretty common jam and it's
very easy to clear
yeah but i guess he was like freaking
out of panicking
and he wasn't really thinking about it
so he's just like [ __ ] it and he just
threw it yeah just threw this [ __ ] down
like a douche and he's standing there
[ __ ] ducking behind looks like a palm
tree and using a little bit of cover
trying to gauge that guy look like he's
about 20 meters away on the other side
of the street
and he gets shot from another angle boom
blows his [ __ ] hits him in the hand
the pistol kind of you could see it move
he didn't
remove the part of his thumb or his
thumb
and he looks at it a couple times for a
few seconds and it looks like he looked
down the barrel and pulled the trigger
and just shot himself right through the
head
it's what it looked like to me at the
time maybe he did put it underneath his
chin and pull the trigger
his heart attack it's kind of hard to
tell it's real low release yeah
it's a real low res and it's kind of
it's a helicopter and the angle
is not really perfect to see what's
going on
through his motions his body movement
it it wasn't like a a moment of gravitas
it felt like just see that's what i was
thinking because i was thinking like if
he was gonna actually shoot himself he'd
be
you'd think he'd be like bracing up for
i'm gonna get you [ __ ]
like you know you're not gonna take me
alive but it wasn't like that it was
almost kind of like i was
playing some [ __ ] yeah it looked like a
klutzy accident to me
i think that's what it i think he was so
spooked and he had been shot in the hand
and he was being overwhelmed by this all
this incoming fire from coming from all
these different directions
i i got a real weird feelings that he
looked down the barrel and pulled the
trigger to make sure the gun was working
i kind of feel like
i think that would happen too i don't
think because on purpose
it hit the bullet hit his thumb and it
and i think it hit the slide
of the pistol and i think it he saw some
kind of superficial damage
and did something like a child would do
look down look down and [ __ ] and
does this work yeah like i said blew
your [ __ ] head off
that's what i think happened hey it
worked oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah just think working with zach
yeah
don't do that kids yeah yeah so uh so
yeah
so basically the the same time that he
gets shot in the wrist
um the cops again shooting at him they
also shot the
rifle that he was firing and it uh broke
it
like he couldn't uh fire anymore
so uh all right so at this point
there is the lapd calls in uh
another officer down call like i said
cops are getting shot
um nobody died thankfully but um a lot
of
officers did get injured during this
[ __ ] amazingly nobody got killed
so at this point the swat team shows up
and this is about 18 minutes after the
shooting had started because they had
called them earlier
now uh the swat team had ar-15s the
funny thing
was that they had been uh on a run
like when they got called so they all
had like their little jogging shorts and
[ __ ] on but they had then they had like
the armor over it
so they they all came uh you know to do
the [ __ ]
and uh so at this point they come in
and they knew that there were some
officers down and there was one in
particular
uh that was really really injured that
was like hiding behind a tree and he was
like
dying like for real like he had been
shot in like a major artery in the leg
and he was like bleeding out
and he was going unconscious and they
couldn't get to him because of all the
fire
so basically when the swat team got
there they
happened to be an armored truck going by
and they commandeered
the armored truck um you know from the
guy because they called into the company
whatever i don't know if it was brinks
or whoever it was
and they called in and said hey we need
this to come in and like pick up
everybody that's been injured so that's
basically uh
what they did they had to extract
because there have been like civilians
and [ __ ] like that that have been uh
wounded also
so they took this armored truck like
through the [ __ ] and picked up all the
people that were
wounded now at this point uh emile
had been shot three times now he'd been
shot
in the right side of his butt uh he'd
also been shot in the
right leg and he'd been shot in the left
forearm now what see i didn't really
realize that
yeah there's a lot of and and that was
unarmored
yeah emil only had the vest
okay which was augmented right but he
didn't have the [ __ ] like larry had all
the [ __ ] with like arms legs
shin guards everything uh emil didn't
have that i think all he had was the
vest and like a cup
a lot of times what happens you know if
you ever go through a good live fire
range even if it's a [ __ ]
like blank fire range where you're
fighting with a bunch of other dudes in
in the military all that running around
especially if you're weighted down you
get very hot and sweaty
if you add a couple of [ __ ] bullet
wounds to that even in non-vital areas
that'll really sap your willpower away
i would imagine that those between all
this fighting
those [ __ ] weird mental states that
[ __ ] steroids
put you into all this [ __ ] stress
the weight the heat and all these guys
shooting at you and you being shot a
couple times
i kind of think you i kind of think
maybe your will to live starts to get
you definitely can't think too straight
and you're probably dumb to begin with
then your will to [ __ ] kind of
your will to kind of [ __ ] continue
can can kind of get
can kind of wear down well i kind of
feel i get the impression
that these two like i said they had done
it this wasn't their first rodeo they'd
done this a couple times they had done
armored cars they had done a couple
banks
and i'm assuming like it had gone off
without much of a hitch
prior so i kind of feel like they
thought that was going to happen this
time
and even though they were prepared for a
big response i don't think you can ever
really be prepared for that
if you've never had it happen to you
before all this getting shot and
shooting at guys
and then losing cars and trying to
hijack a couple of cars and lugging that
armor around and that
bags of [ __ ] money that already have
die on them and all that [ __ ]
i'd imagine you're [ __ ] hating life
by that point
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] i imagine you're
[ __ ] seeing red
and just ready to give up at any moment
yeah because
they went down fighting but maybe that
dude did just say [ __ ] it i'm out of
here [ __ ] blew his head off
maybe but like i said it's it's hard to
tell the body language is happening so
fast it looked occidental
actually to me and like i said the even
the cops didn't know because they
thought we couldn't really tell if he
did it on purpose or not right
but yeah so so emile had been shot three
times at this point
uh and at this point he had the duffel
bag full of money three hundred thousand
dollars three or three thousand dollars
but it was marked at this point and it
yeah the dye packet exploded
so it was useless so he threw it away uh
he gets in their
car their getaway car and starts it up
um at this point larry comes around to
the car and i guess they had the uh the
hk91 was in the trunk which was open
so he got that out of the trunk and he
started uh
firing at the officers and walking
alongside the car
yeah using the car for coverage yeah
sense to me when i was seeing this cars
looks really weird on the video i have
to say cars are not covered
okay even nine millimeter will go
through that it's just
a series of sheet metal pieces of sheet
metal nine will go right through that
why did he just get in the damn car and
shoot the back window out shoot the cops
brilliant it didn't make any sense to me
i'm not entirely
he was trying to walk along the side of
the car like he's the presidential
escort and [ __ ]
shooting back at the cops stay away from
my car and protecting this [ __ ] you
can't hurt me
they were shooting him and it didn't
make any sense to me no it didn't
it was it was crazy-looking should have
jumped in the back shot the back window
out [ __ ] started
returning fire see tom's got all kind of
tips for bank robbers out there
well don't do this [ __ ] no it's military
stuff that's what we would well yeah
i know i'm just all about the same i'm
just making which is very different from
law enforcement law enforcement's trying
to
you know prevent civilian casualties
they're trying to make arrests they're
worried about [ __ ] adhering to laws
and regulations
the military isn't like that you don't
give a [ __ ] about civilians you're an
enemy territory you don't give a [ __ ]
about
their laws you're not in your country
you're trying to put
maximum [ __ ] damage and terror on the
opponent
and you're trying to minimize your own
risk at the same time you know
so i just got in the damn car shot out
the back
you know yeah you would think i mean
that that would be the smart thing why
would you walk alongside the car
just get in the [ __ ] car get the [ __ ]
out of there you could go
you could go totally mexican cartel and
just start [ __ ] nailing civilians
too and just say you follow me i'll kill
more civilians
because that works in mexico city they
got proof of that
they arrested one of those cartel agents
so [ __ ] the cartel just randomly went
out and just started shooting people
and then they called the news and they
said to release him or we're just gonna
kill all these people and the president
said okay release him
because they will what else are you
gonna do they'll kill four or five six
hundred thousand people they'll just
endless people
so yeah brad made the point that heat
came out in 1995 and
i'm pretty sure that uh that the bank
robbers got a lot of ideas from that
yeah see that's what i thought you know
what i mean yeah i i was pretty sure and
it's just
that one scene and then the armored car
scene
yeah yeah that's a good news though the
thing is those dudes were mostly [ __ ]
ex-military doing that in the movie
yeah these guys not them these guys
weren't all right they were just uh
they were kind of maybe high on their
own supply kind of thing
they they kind of thought they were
smarter than they were yeah which is
always dangerous
and this is a big this is much ado about
nothing there's other ways to make money
there's other ways to steal money with a
lot less risk
yeah this is almost kind of like the not
a really good way to go
hollywood flam hollywood inspired
flamboyancy
well there's a certain type of dude
there's a certain type of personality
yeah like they can't just
take the easier path yeah they can't
just be like well i'm gonna do a legal
[ __ ] anyway so it's like you know i'm
gonna steal this money because i just
want money but they also have to have
center of attention they also have to be
the center yeah yeah
it's like some weird kind of like
narcissism kind of thing and those kind
of dudes usually end up getting killed
but unfortunately they usually take some
people with them thankfully these people
did not
but that one guy that possibly yeah well
they did
yeah like not on this job but they had
like allegedly killed someone else
uh prior like on a on a previous job but
i'm just like i'm still amazed that
nobody got killed
on this ship because it's like [ __ ]
amazing yeah so so yeah so he's walking
alongside the car right
now he's at this point so
he's coming up to uh you know he's
walking alongside the car
and then one of the cops uh rounds hit
him in the shoulder
and then his uh rifle got hit again
uh in the receiver and the magazine
now he's only uh one armed at this point
larry is
uh so he's trying to like shoot with one
arm and then he just
throws the hk91 away and then he gets
the
the other one which is the uh norenko
the type 56
yeah it's another ak yeah and then he uh
he
goes out of the parking lot and then he
goes on the street and then emil keeps
driving the car
down the street now it's almost 10 a.m
at this point it's 9
52 a.m larry uh he goes down archwood
street
and he hides behind a uh semi
uh truck and he is still shooting at the
cops and then his rifle jammed uh so
this is what we were mentioning earlier
now he couldn't clear the jam we don't
know why
maybe he had a damaged hand well he did
he'd been shot in the wrist and i think
he'd also been shot so maybe he couldn't
clear it
yeah it just hurt too much to clear it
because like i said a lot of the cops
are saying that too because they're like
that's a really easy that's a very
common like thing to have he might have
had damage to his hands before
and he couldn't do it yeah xander said
crazy do you think this took place in
the am too before lunchtime
it's like i think about this kind of
[ __ ] because it's like yeah it's like
nine
[ __ ] 30 in the morning you could just
be like out running errands or whatever
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] like
transpires holy crap but yeah so
he couldn't clear the jam so he throws
the rifle away and then he draws
uh his beretta pistol and then started
firing that
at that point uh he gets shot in the
right hand
now he'd been shot in the left wrist
before so he gets shot in the right hand
so i couldn't clear that malfunction
maybe yeah that's probably why his hand
was probably couldn't move it's probably
numb as [ __ ] just
yeah you would think i mean if you got
shot through the wrist and it's sapping
his will and [ __ ] too
yep so uh so yeah so he gets shot in the
right hand uh by officer conrado torres
and then he dropped the pistol then he
picks it back up
and like you said he puts it the muzzle
of it under the under his chin
and fired it so
uh at the same time that this happened
apparently one of
um the the rounds fired by the cops
actually shot him in the back i think it
shot him in the back or like in the
front like it severed his spine yeah i
think he got hit by sniper fire
he did at the exact same time yeah now
like i said they're not real sure and
even the cops that were there were not
entirely sure if he shot himself in the
head on purpose
or if it was an accident to me it looked
like an
accident but i don't know i wasn't there
um i'm just watching the footage
to me it looked like he was maybe trying
to be like hey what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this or he just maybe wasn't
thinking about his hands were both his
hands were [ __ ] up at this point
um so he probably wasn't but i don't i
don't know if he necessarily
shot himself on purpose body language
looks like i think he did it by accident
there's another case where they got this
little short black dude [ __ ] robbing
a bank he's got a pistol in his hand he
drops some money
and somehow drops the pistol at the same
time picks the pistol back up and looks
down the barrel and pulls the trigger
boom and he blows his own [ __ ] by
accident
whoops don't look down the barrel of a
pistol yeah and the [ __ ] money goes
that's the lesson the money was in his
hands and it goes and fluttering down
like [ __ ]
feathers and [ __ ] it almost makes you
feel bad like not really but
almost dude had no idea how to handle a
firearm no idea
at all clearly i mean yeah you can see
that you can find it
he's [ __ ] he looks right down the
barrel and pulls the trigger does this
work
that's [ __ ] crazy why would you
why was that even occur to you to do
that why is this not working
what the [ __ ] never fired a gun before
at least that's about how i remembered
it might have hit the
he had it in his hand and he dropped it
and picks it back up and shoots himself
in the face
i mean because it shocked him that he
dropped it
even people that have that don't have a
lot of experience with firearms
you know that the bullet comes out that
end
and that if you put that end towards
your face
then maybe it will come out and kill you
well i mean you'd think that would be
common
if i remember correctly it was something
like a 1911 it was a single action
semi-auto which means that the hammer's
cocked and it's got a real [ __ ] short
trigger pull
so it doesn't take much five pounds of
pull it's not a long
like revolver type pull it's a little
short pull
and he had it in his hand and he's
plumbing with the money and drops the
pistol a little bit
grabs the pistol when it hits the
[ __ ] counter and
somehow shoots himself do it during that
catching the pistol and trying to
get back control of it he points it
right at his face
right underneath his like he said
underneath his jaw and
and i guess he grabbed the butt and
cram the grab it's just clearly on on
video
security that he shot himself right
through the bottom of the [ __ ] face
with his own pistol during some kind of
weird fumble
and what happened to what's his name
george larry
larry scared what happened to larry look
look almost like a similar fumble
got shot in the hand and i it's like he
was checking his hand in the pistol
and and did this he was making it
yeah and it was kind of like he was
fumbling with it
there wasn't any dramatic [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
i'm out of here you think you'd brace up
and go oh you know what i mean there
wasn't any of that it was just happened
so fast like a fumble
but yeah probably surprised him yeah
more than anybody
else he just slumps boom falls like a
sack of [ __ ]
camp guys said i can't watch stuff like
that anymore it's not real graphic
i mean basically it's just kind of like
thank you victor sorry i'm late start
over
oh my god see it looks very different
from a guy who shoots himself on head on
purpose i've seen videos of that
guy i see that's what i was thinking it
just looked very anti-climactic yeah
that's what it did
there's one where there's a damn
helicopter
the cops are chasing a van van goes off
the road goes into a swampy area
[ __ ] he loses control of the van
[ __ ] he gets out he's running the
cops i'll get out and chase him he's
running on top of a hill the
helicopter's watching him he
stands there like this i can't take it
anymore pulls out a pistol
blows his head off on live television
and um
but you could see that he was going to
do it and then announced that wait hold
on turn it off turn it off turn it off
and go
it was up yeah because there was like a
build to it yeah there's a big building
this one was just
kind of like fast yeah right and you
would think there would be a big build
up
and every time i've seen a guy on video
shoot himself on purpose there's a build
up to it
because he's got to get himself psyched
up to pull that damn trigger
you know well a lot of times i think
like i said it's that personality type
where they're just like [ __ ]
she might be doing this yeah
it's kind of like that kind of [ __ ] like
they have to go out like with they have
to make a big deal about it what was so
funny about the kid that shot himself it
was a kid that shot himself he wasn't
really wandered for anything
that's much much ado about nothing well
that's what kills me about like people
who get pulled over and it's like
then they're just like they make a big
deal like they shoot themselves
and i've seen this happen a couple of
times and it's like they had like an
outstanding warrant it was just like for
pot possession
this kid like no license no driver's
license
you know so he's going to run so he he
goes on
10 minutes chase
and then [ __ ] it i can't be arrested
boom
it did wouldn't have done any time yeah
that's what i mean it would have been a
pain in the ass but that's about all it
would have been
like they're not going to put you in
prison for 30 years or something like
that
a couple months jesus christ like i said
it would have been a pain in the ass at
worst
just i don't know they don't know what
they're facing they just they think
dude that was the end of the word they
thought it was the end of the world or
something i don't know i'm always kind
of one of the people
well well let's see how this is going to
shake out yeah
it might not be as bad as i'm expecting
they're gonna put handcuffs on me [ __ ]
it goodbye cruel world
dudes are such drama queens oh my god
so so yeah so basically well they didn't
know if he was
dead well i mean they were pretty sure
he was dead but like so the cops like go
up to him
uh they kept shooting at him just to
make sure
uh you know they shot his body several
times because they were like is the
[ __ ] dead okay
so then they like walk up to him they
put uh handcuffs on him even though he's
probably already dead at this point and
took his mask off
now at this point emil uh he
was at like uh the cops had shot out a
couple of his tires
uh and they had shot the windshield out
so uh at about four minutes to ten in
the morning
he's he tried to carjack a
jeep that was going down the street so
he was shooting at the driver
uh the driver ran away um at you know as
you would because the dude was shooting
at you
um but i guess the cool thing was that
the dude that was driving the jeep he
got carjacked and he's like yeah i'm
getting out of the car but he took his
keys with him
yeah i'm trying to mail like to
he takes all the [ __ ] out of the good
way he puts it in the jeep and he's like
oh
how much you want to be old boy didn't
even plan that he just took the keys
automatically without thinking about it
like you do when you get out of the car
he probably even played yeah he probably
wasn't even liking it
this dude just a [ __ ] well yeah
because when you get out of the car you
just take the keys
that's just something that you do like
without you probably did it without you
thinking about it so he's just probably
like hey i'm taking the keys bye and
then he sees the dude
oh i [ __ ] him over yeah nice i didn't
even mean to do that
prepper [ __ ] brings up a good one the
dude's shooting himself in the head and
prepping goes he needs some milk
there you go that's a good thing that's
a good viral call back he needs some
milk
i guess he did yeah not gonna do him
much good now though no
is it where is tila i have not seen
teela tayla isn't here and
um sandra isn't here oh yeah sandra's
not here either yeah
also if he's not here yeah sophie isn't
here sandra isn't here she's doing
something bad in germany
something breast augmentation something
involving peanut butter and
peanut butter and breast augmentation
breast augmentation and a tube top i'm
sure it's involved
all right so you talked for a minute
because i gotta i gotta go to the
bathroom i gotta get a picture of sandra
one of these days she says i wouldn't
like her
are you still listening what oh because
she's too scared
and she says i guess she says she's too
skinny she's too skinny
wearing [ __ ] hold on let me change my
hair
i gotta change my hair
i'm gonna put on my [ __ ] french
pervert hat
hair hat i'm gonna put on like uh put
this [ __ ] on
this is oh [ __ ] man how do i [ __ ] put
this [ __ ] on
trying to figure out which way this goes
um
okay
man yeah now i'm now a french director
this is my roman polanski wig
yeah what do you guys think of that
he needs some milk see
who's roasting in cali oh you talking
about uh uh a tea
we got robert smith no man this is my
this is my uh roman polanski wig
oh my god you're doing that what's that
yeah it's my roman folasky wig that
doesn't look damaged like roman polanski
i had to cut with some i was thinking
like a french film director or something
yeah okay
so for some reason i just i'll allow it
i'm a polanski i'll allow it he's not
french though he's pulling
he lives down there now
from his rape charges yeah
i'm trying to figure out who like you
remind me of somebody but i can't think
of who it is i think i'm like
you know what i mean mick mars mick mars
from
i don't like this wig as much for some
reason it just does not have the impact
oh it does not happen you need to spike
it up you want some hairspray no
i got time for that [ __ ] it does not
have the impact
of the [ __ ] willy wonka wig
it's not quite as ridiculous not as
[ __ ] ridiculous
i become an insane michael kane with
this
man i'm gonna oh his birthday is coming
up soon michael caine
no yours and i'm gonna get you some
what kind of wig should i get tom for
his birthday
the more ridiculous the better i don't
know man can i get you like a princess
kind of wig like a [ __ ]
no no girl wigs what you're not fun
i got that long black one over there
that's my ozzy osbourne wig
that's already a girl's wig but well the
thing about just long straight black
hair that's pretty uh androgynous
that could that could be either that
could be anything yeah
uh my carrot top wig
maybe i'll get you a rainbow clown wig
i don't care or that's looking terrible
maybe
oh you know it'd be cool it's like if uh
you remember back in the old days when
they had this big [ __ ] like
back in mozart times when they had those
big [ __ ] giant wigs that like ships
and swans and [ __ ] like that in there
like the big [ __ ] all the all the
aristocracy wore that [ __ ] maybe i'll
get you one of those
i actually i wouldn't mind one of those
i wear that tom baker wig he says that's
my tom baker wig
oh my god all right yeah so okay let's
finish the case today so hot the west
coast right now yeah it's not here too
actually it was 90. i think when we
started the show it was 90 something
yeah degrees santa says the ar-15 is
better because it's american
that's not better because it's american
it's just looking better because it's
just so modular you can turn one into
anything
and you know between the ar-15 and the
ar-10 and everything that happened
things that you can do in this there's a
damn just a diaspora of all these
[ __ ] companies that make [ __ ] for
that
you can just make anything out any of
those ars they're just it's just so
modular it's great
but really when it comes to what's best
out of all those second ars and eugene
stoner designs out of armalite
the ar-18 the stamped metal one
they never really got it developed it
only went through like one
iteration but that was pretty cool too
that was kind of like
crosston an ar and an ak and that
bull carrier and gas system that's used
on all these new
weapons all the new ones use that ar-18
or ar 180 operating system
everything else is just different
trigger mechanism different receiver
plastic [ __ ] but that ar 18 really
and that was the one the [ __ ]
terminator and t1 shot the police up
with was a ar180
well there you go yeah that was badass
[ __ ] a lot of people think it's a k2
rifle a daewoo k2 it's not it's an ar
ar18
all right eamon cowan says i think
that's where the term big wig comes from
the aristocracy wearing those huge wigs
that would make sense yeah some of those
like i said some of those were pretty
rad
like they were ridiculous but i don't
know there's something i like about
ridiculous if you're gonna like lean
into the [ __ ] like i said
some of them had like whole [ __ ] ship
models and [ __ ] in there
i'm sure that was like you'd have to go
to the party and your head would weigh
like a hundred pounds
so you'd only be able to stay for a
little while should be like yeah i'm
getting like a headache i gotta go home
but you know it looks cool when you
first came in and that's really all that
matters isn't it
yeah all right so what oh yeah i was
gonna say so yeah the
the ira had some ar 180s
but that's because i was in whitey
bulger sending a whole bunch of them out
of boston
yeah that's right you could get you
could get your hands on them in the
united states they weren't real
desirable most people wanted the ar-15
but ar180s were the semi-auto version
and the ira ended up getting a bunch of
them um
they were good they just they needed to
be developed a couple more generations
but they would have been really good had
they been around for a long time they
were very light
fast to produce and they were
inexpensive and they were good they were
kind of like an american version of an
ak
mixed with an ar-15 okay prepper pov
says those old-time mozart wigs are at
least resistant to low
low velocity rounds yeah yeah yeah
probably
yeah so as long as you were shooting at
their hair
like they totally [ __ ] holy crap
all right so i probably need another
drink okay here are making one yeah
right
same thing yeah yeah i like the orange
juice actually
uh okay so so poor emil at this point
because larry is
[ __ ] dead uh so he like takes all the
trouble of taking all of their [ __ ]
weaponry and transferring it to this car
that he thinks he's carjacked uh but he
can't start it
uh for whatever it is because the dude
took the keys or whatever so he can't
start it
um so at this point there's like uh
helicopters like news helicopters
and they were uh kind of uh overhead
filming everything
and then there was some swat guys
and they were in a patrol car and they
stopped like they pulled up on the
other side of the truck uh to where the
where emil had left the car because he
was like i said he was unloading
so emil gets out of the truck and then
hi like he ducks behind the original uh
getaway car which is the chevy
and he started like shooting at them so
this went on for like two or three
minutes where they were like all just
like shooting at each other
now at this point like one of these swat
guys
i guess um hit him in the chest but
because he had uh
oh thanks because he had the vest and he
had the trauma plate in there like it
bounced off
uh but it did wind him i guess so
at this point um the one of the swat
guys
like decides hey i'm gonna start firing
the ar-15 like underneath
the cars and like shoot the dude's legs
so that's what he started doing
so because emil's legs were not
protected he was shooting under the car
and like he uh
he basically got his legs shot out from
under him and he
uh got shot up and he started putting
his hands up like he was giving up
right now at this point uh
he seemed to be surrendering so all
these cops like rushed in
and they pinned him down and put
handcuffs on him
uh the swat guys asked what his name was
he said his name was pete
like you would which is not his name
um now at this point there had been
rumors going around that there might
have been a third guy
like back at the bank still like holding
the hostages uh you know holding the
hostages
so they asked him about that they said
are there any more
dudes because they knew the wounded was
dead um
at which point emil replied politely
[ __ ] you
shoot me in the head that's what he said
yeah
uh but they did not do that and honestly
there's been like kind of a lot of
speculation over whether
they just let the dude bleed out or
whether it was a case of well the
ambulance couldn't really get in there
because it was hot zone
because they have a thing like the
ambulance can't come in there if they
think they're still firing and like i
said at this point they weren't sure if
there was a third suspect like back at
the bank still
so you know they weren't like letting a
lot of ambulances in there and like i
said even some of the cops
that that had been hit um the ambulances
couldn't get in there to get them like
some of the swat guys like came in like
in the armored car
that they commandeered like to get some
of the dudes because one of the dudes
was gonna die for sure
because he was like bleeding out he'd
been shot a bunch of times in the legs
and whatnot
um so because basically they let
a meal uh bleed out
yeah essentially well i think the way
they saw it is that uh you know they had
all these other people that they had to
uh
yeah they were cops and civilians and
yeah like that though was at the [ __ ]
last of them
yeah i mean and brightly so yeah he was
the one that did all the [ __ ]
and it kills me that like later on like
after this happened i feel like emil's
relatives like tried to sue the lapd
like saying oh you let him bleed to
death and i'm just kind of like even if
they did
i so
there were other i mean there were other
people that needed like he [ __ ] i
don't know that you know did they did
they give him any first aid i don't even
know if they even gave him any first aid
you could have [ __ ] put some
tourniquets on his [ __ ] legs
keep just bleeding down but uh he would
probably lost those legs anyway
after all the tourniquetting and [ __ ] i
mean he's been shot ribbons from the
[ __ ]
he got he i think he was shot 29 times
yeah not all in the legs but he'd been
shot like
he was shot in the butt he was shot in
the arm yeah but he was shot like a
bunch of times in the legs
um enough that he was he bled out like
in about an hour
but that was the thing like he just kind
of laid there
and uh they had taken all his weapons
away he was handcuffed so he was laying
there
and he was um apparently like asking
them for help like the cops
now the cops did radio for an ambulance
like everybody said that
um but i was customized you didn't let
me die aren't you
yeah he was just like swearing at them
and he's just and he kept saying just
shoot me just shoot me just shoot me
yeah um you know he he was he's full of
[ __ ] really when you think about it
that dude didn't want to live because he
never would have been the man he was in
his life he doesn't spend the rest of
his life behind bars and probably
without any legs
okay yeah he wouldn't have he wouldn't
enjoy it it was better that he died
just saying better for him than he died
yeah and i mean the thing about it is
he's an egotistical [ __ ] and a
bodybuilder and [ __ ] he didn't want to
be
[ __ ] in a wheelchair the rest of his
life [ __ ] locked up behind bars like
a
thank you wasting away in prison and
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they did him a favor by letting him die
yeah that's me
and i mean yeah there was other people
that they had to [ __ ] evacuate
and uh that's what i'm saying it's like
it ended up like
there was well i wasn't cooperating they
thought there was somebody still out
there
i think there was like uh i think 12
cops got shot up and i think it was
eight civilians i think if i'm
remembering traveling
so there were other people that they had
to get to that like the ambulance had to
get to and like i said it's policy like
the ambulance can't come and do like
they said like i said they call it the
hot zone
uh it's like there was still like active
fire they weren't sure if there was a
third
suspect or not so the ambulance they
didn't want to come in there because
they don't want to get shot up
and like i said even some of the cops
were down
and the ambulance couldn't get in to get
them either so i don't think they were
like picking on him specifically
um but on the other hand they probably
didn't like go out of their way to
[ __ ] make him any more comfortable
either because why would you
like i said it was typical la [ __ ]
too bad traffic and stuff [ __ ] well
yeah l.a
not enough not enough [ __ ] ambulance
support and stuff i mean it's kind of
like
[ __ ] and uh l.a what it takes
like a [ __ ]
hour to get anywhere yeah and he had
been shooting in 45 minutes he and his
buddy those cops weren't gonna [ __ ]
help that dude out he's gonna be last
on their phone yeah it's like they're
not gonna go out of their way are they
like i said i wouldn't either if it was
me because i'm just kind of like
i'll help you eventually like after we
get the good
innocent people like i haven't [ __ ]
like taken care of
so yeah so he was shot 29 times uh it
took the ambulance about 70 minutes to
get there
got a super chat yeah it's like uh yeah
gotta read it out
thank you david okay that is a tom baker
wig and jenny take on the daleks
yeah they're not here exterminating yeah
yeah
grampur's hammer says cops don't really
do first aid other than cpr yes
that's what i thought they just they
just i mean they did call an ambulance
for the dude
so they did do that um but it just took
them a long time to get there so i don't
know if they necessarily did it on
purpose like
no they didn't let you bleed they don't
do first aid then there's nothing they
can do
that's what i mean it's like well you
[ __ ] around and found out
yeah i mean basically i i don't really
have too much sympathy for the dude
um so yeah so like i said this whole
thing was like
[ __ ] broadcast live like you said you
saw it on uh tv
and uh basically they had over 300 cops
respond to this and uh by the time
the incident ended larry and emile had
fired eleven hundred
rounds which is around every two seconds
counting because it took about forty 45
there's an amazing amount of ammunition
they'd [ __ ] poured downrange
and they were going in the trunk getting
more come out
yeah yeah just shooting everything up i
mean
it's a miracle that [ __ ] they didn't
[ __ ] kill anybody but
that still amazes me like i said now one
of the cops there was one cop i can't
what his name was it started with a z
but he uh got shot uh pretty
kind of early on in the fire fight and
he dragged himself i think it was like
30 yards like and he was like hiding
behind a tree and he was bleeding out
i mean they had um because one of the
documentaries i saw like the woman that
was like the dispatcher
and she was talking to him and she was
trying to keep him awake because he was
just kind of like i'm losing
consciousness i'm leaving
because he was losing blood right and uh
the ambulance couldn't get in there to
get him
so he was one of the guys that the swat
team had to come when they commandeered
the uh
the armored car and they came in they
got him and honestly he had been shot
to hell and he lost so much blood that
i'm like amazed that he survived so he
like
had the worst injuries but he did live
so like i said
everybody that got shot like a bunch of
cops got shot mostly they got shot like
in the ankles or the arms or you know
they just got grazed
like in the butt or whatever um so most
of them did live
civilians were a couple of them were
shot
a couple of them were uh had like you
know gun butts in the head and
things like that so they were injured
but they didn't die
and honestly i can't believe like
watching it
watching the footage now because like i
said this is a bank of america there's
like [ __ ] all around there there's like
a [ __ ]
there's a del taco over there there's
houses all over the place
this is looks like a neighborhood like
behind there and the fact that they were
just like spraying this whole [ __ ]
area
with rounds and nobody got killed even
accidentally
is [ __ ] amazing that's amazing i mean
a lot of people got shot but nobody died
which to me is amazing yeah yeah some
guys got shot up pretty bad some of the
cops
they did yeah um like i said that one
guy got shot up pretty bad but
but he uh he did live even though i
don't know how he did because he was
just like [ __ ] bleeding and he was
laying there for like a really really
really long time
like even when i was watching the
documentary i was like stressing out
about the dude because i'm like
he's still there holy [ __ ] and he was
just kind of like i'm losing
consciousness i'm losing like because
they had all of the
you know they had all the recordings of
like his [ __ ] whatever
so so yeah so they have like wikipedia
had a list of all the uh
injuries yeah it was 12 police officers
and eight civilians
uh yeah sergeant larry dean haynes
hitting the left shoulder
uh officer martin whitfield shot and
seriously wounded four times in the left
arm right femur and chest
officer conrado torres uh grazed the
right side of the neck
uh james uh van
yeah that's what i was thinking of he
was shot twice seriously when he got
shot in the lower back hip and thigh
yeah so it was all so he was like
bleeding all over the place that was who
i was thinking of
uh william krulack uh hit in the right
ankle
he was a detective detective tracy
angeles
grazed in the stomach and buttock
officer stewart guy hit twice in the
right femur and right forearm
detective earl valadares hid in the head
by flying debris officer ed brentlinger
hit by gunfire and by concrete fragments
on his face left forearm
officer william lance hit in the right
knee officer john goodman hit by flying
glass and shrapnel
officer david grimes injured in a
traffic accident which i guess it was
like i said this was a claustromark also
a few civilians
there was a woman named mildred nolte uh
struck across the face by one of the
perpetrators john villagrana who was the
assistant manager of the bank of america
struck across the head by the stock of
an assault rifle
javier orozco struck across the face
very golding hit by flying glass and
shrapnel
tracy fisher hit in the left ankle
michael horan
hit in the left side of the chest jose
jose harrow
hit by flying glass and shrapnel and
william marr hit by glass and shrapnel
fragments in the right arm left temple
and nose
so like i said fairly minor minor
injuries
other than a couple of the cops yeah now
all this
in summation all of this could have been
avoided had the lapd
issued out assault rifles to policemen
now some people that don't know what i'm
talking about civilians they may be
horrified
what do you mean you're going to give
these weapons of war
to the cops man you know the [ __ ] you're
talking about all right
a weapon of war is a [ __ ] tank
[ __ ] a napalm bomb or a jet
it's just a regular old [ __ ] rifle
it's a good combat rifle
law enforcement's been using rifles and
carbines going all the way back to the
[ __ ] 1700s
there's nothing unusual there none of
this happened by accident
these two dudes saw the gap they said
those cops only have [ __ ] pistols
if we [ __ ] put on body armor and have
[ __ ] rifles we can keep them out of
it
out at a distance where they're not
threatening to us where they wouldn't be
a threat we could dominate us
dominate them so that's exactly what
they did they tried to dominate a
military style
with using firepower and [ __ ]
weaponry
not a good solution long term though
like you said that bottom 40
44 minutes until they eventually got
taken out
just not a good long-term strategy but
you can nip all this [ __ ] in the butt if
your police have parody with
normal parody within with what an
offender can get
and have a normal combat carbine or a
rifle
that way the advantage isn't there so he
can't
walk around like he's king [ __ ] swinging
a dick and [ __ ]
busting an entire police unit around
because they don't have [ __ ] rifles
you know that's the job of a bad guy or
a [ __ ] soldier is to find the
weakness of your enemy and
exploit it all right
if you have a weakness it will be
exploited so the police have to be
well-rounded
they have to be able to deal with things
that
will commonly happen a do with a rifle
okay
now some things are just not [ __ ]
normal like the time that dude stole the
m60 battle tank and rode that [ __ ] down
the road
cops weren't ready for that that's a
special okay this is a very special
occasion that's a weapon of war
all right by the time that the dude
[ __ ] made his own
custom tank and destroyed the [ __ ]
town remember we did the show on that
with the killdozer see yeah see the
documentary
tread yeah we talked about it a while
yeah it's really crazy i think it's on
netflix
made his own tank out of a gigantic
bulldozer as one [ __ ] up
everything there was no way to stop it
that's what it does okay they eventually
got him though
but that was just because he got stuck
all right yeah
um well he uh that was kind of like a
suicide mission yeah
he uh you know pretty much
i mean he wasn't planning on coming out
of there right he sealed himself inside
that [ __ ]
right just rest assured that nothing
that there's nothing you can do
you cannot child proof the world
we live in a dangerous world if somebody
wants to get you
and they're intelligent and have the
resources and the [ __ ] discipline
they'll get you okay they'll make of
their own tanks if they have to
you just cannot child proof the world i
mean but most of the time most people
are
most times all right trouble most of the
time you know most people aren't going
to most people don't do it but there's
just no way to prevent everything
so you have to have your law enforcement
guys
ready for your average well-rounded [ __ ]
pistols rifles shotguns some
air support you know from helicopters um
they they're gonna need backup from
other officers and good communications
and i mean they did have that to an
extent because the swat
team did have all that [ __ ] they did
have enough [ __ ] but it took them
a while to get there swat teams are
special teams takes a long time to
mobilize them and a lot of times those
aren't full-time swat guys
they're like on a detail they're
detailed out for that they're doing
other things at the time you need them
you have to call them
okay it's better if just every [ __ ]
patrol car has a [ __ ] little car
being in there
556 a little m4
m16 something like that for every
officer has that
either up in the cab or out in the trunk
to where if he runs out runs across the
dangerous situation you can pull that up
it's so much better than a pistol this
whole
concept that a cop has to have a pistol
is just that's
antiquated thinking it's wrong thinking
because they never had that in the past
they didn't have that in the 1800s
a policeman in the 1800s had a pistol
but he also had a lever action carbine
or a
lever action rifle or a [ __ ]
double-barreled sawed-off shotgun
so they even back in the day they were
well armed
well and this uh this particular
incident
was what spurred now like cops in
california now have uh yeah they all
carry carbon semi-automatic gravel
yeah yeah which is that's the basic
that's just a basic
well-rounded good firearm
you know pistols are not good firearms
they're an emergency
last-ditch survival tool the military
does not even consider them to be
weapons
they can more consider them to be a
badge of authority
an officer will carry that to show you
that he doesn't have to carry a rifle
that he's an officer
when in combat a lot of times rifle an
officer won't even carry that
he'll carry a rifle though because he
doesn't want to be
singled out as an officer and killed by
a sniper whoever got a pistol kill that
[ __ ]
that's usually what a sniper does so
even the military does not consider
pistols to be
weapons per se they
the weapon thing starts at about ar-15
i mean yeah it's a weapon but it's a
defensive weapon and armies aren't about
defense
they're about offense yeah i was
so what i mentioned earlier was that
this kind of kills me like i get it
but it still kind of kills me so emile
uh mata serenu's family uh
sued the lapd uh
not too long after this incident
basically claiming well the lapd
uh let emile bleed to death
like on purpose so
they brought it to court uh and it was
actually tried
in uh spring of 2000
and ended in a mistrial now at this
point like the suit was dropped
because i guess the family said they
would dismiss it
or whatever but it does seem like look i
get that's your family member
and i it kills me too that this email
dude had kids right because that's who
was suing that was his it was his grown
children
can you imagine like if your dad did
some [ __ ] like that well from your point
of view he's your dad you know what i
mean so you just
if my dad pulled some [ __ ] like this i'd
be like yeah well that's what happens
you don't know the mentality of them
though they're they might have saw him
as a
is kind of like a folk hero like yeah
[ __ ] that you don't know what the
attitude
of that family was maybe i don't know
it's just kind of like i try to think
about that all the time because
you know you know what i mean you know
when we talk about like btk
and this is something that fascinates me
i think this is why i liked the movie
the clove pitch killer so much
because it kind of explored that thing
that fascinates me about what if you
were married to somebody
that was a serial killer for like 20
years and you didn't know and then you
found out like what would that feel like
so that's like a really fascinating
thing to me so i'm always kind of
interested if somebody in my family like
my dad or my brother or something
they wouldn't but it you know if they
did hypothetically
if they did like make a big splat and
you knew it was them like it was on tv
and everything like they did a full
[ __ ]
you know bank heist and like they were
just like yeah kill me
but it was just like ev you know what
how would that make me feel
i don't know it's like it's it's an
interesting like thought experiment like
i said it's
it's kind of like academic to me because
i know my dad and my brothers probably
wouldn't do that kind of stuff you guys
wouldn't do that right
i don't know if you guys are listening
but like i said i have two brothers i
don't know
but uh you know and they're lovely
people but i don't know
if i don't know how i would feel about
it i can only go back to what
what i remember uh people saying people
that knew him they said that they
[ __ ] hated california they
hated [ __ ] um uh the lapd
that they felt like they were behind
enemy lines well that's cool like
you know most people don't like the lapd
i get that but it's just kind of like
this seems a little uh extreme it's a
little extreme
reaction i don't think i think they
disliked them for a very different
reason other people disliked him though
basically what you're dealing with is
that they did not like the government of
california
they they had a fundamental differences
with it right but still no
and they saw the lapd as the [ __ ] arm
of that government they just
they evidently kind of saw themselves
as behind enemy lines in a country that
they didn't like
uh and you know that they were just
going to steal and do whatever they
wanted
like i said not a good long-term
strategy if you don't like that [ __ ]
state man go to another [ __ ] state
but yeah that might have just been that
might have just been
what they were telling themselves
to justify going out and trying to steal
a bunch of money
i kind of feel like that so they could
afford sure afford all their [ __ ]
drugs and their steroids so they could
go to muscle beach and chase because
like i said
here's the thing and by god here's the
thing
if they hated it here so much they had
had
no they had had a successful two bank
robberies earlier
1.5 million 1.5 million dollars is
ample money to move elsewhere
if you do not like it where you are yeah
so
the fact that they didn't do that i
think they were i think they were uh
adrenaline junkies i think they liked
robbing these banks
all right yes i don't think it was
anything to do with that that's maybe
what they told themselves but i don't
think that's really what i think they
didn't like california i think they
didn't like the cops but i also think
that they liked robin banks and that
they liked to have a lot of money
and in their minds they were probably
and i think they liked working out and
they liked chasing bikini girls
and they liked [ __ ] going to [ __ ]
muscle beach and [ __ ]
yeah yeah they probably dated
bikini fitness competition girls because
of course they did
yeah well it's that's the female version
of a muscle
chick yeah it's a muscle it's a muscle
girl
and um they wanted money to buy their
[ __ ] they liked guns
they weren't going anywhere they wanted
this they
they wanted people they didn't like to
leave they weren't going to leave they
were going to give up ground they
weren't that kind of guy
and i think they were just super alpha
and uh
kind of dumb and not real [ __ ] uh
thoughtful when it came to like
long-term prospects for survival
clearly i mean okay let's say you do
[ __ ] juice up on a bunch of that
[ __ ] manly ass roid rage okay
and you do [ __ ] go out there manly
ass roy
and you do go out there and [ __ ]
steal 1.5 million dollars
you would think that
that a man would [ __ ] come off his
come off cycle
and go million and a half dollars is a
lot of money
see that's what i would and then you go
if i keep doing this [ __ ] i'm gonna get
caught and get killed
exactly i've gotten away with this yeah
yeah 1.5 million that is
ample money yeah you would think to
survive on you
not only survive you could thrive sure
you could say like
why don't i [ __ ] call it quits i'll
sell off all my [ __ ]
see that's and then go move down to
barbados or something that's what i
would be doing all right or go move down
to [ __ ]
why press your luck yeah you don't have
to go down and [ __ ] buy something out
on the virgin islands
and go stay out there for a [ __ ] good
10 years where you don't place where you
don't really need that much money
that's what i'm saying a million and a
half dollars you could [ __ ] go to a
[ __ ]
one of these developing african nations
and [ __ ]
live like a king there for the rest of
your life like i said you could live
somewhere
that didn't have an extradition treaty
yeah and you could and
had like kind of a low well that
wouldn't even matter living
that wouldn't even matter because they
weren't suspects well right but i mean
just
you know to be on the safe side yeah i'm
just saying if it was me i would charge
i could have gone to some place that was
like an up-and-coming african country
like
nigeria or something or yeah you could
just get like a decent household
i don't need a lot and a hundred
thousand dollars in a country like that
will buy you a [ __ ] mansion that
would be
four million dollars you know what i
mean in florida
you know if you could buy a palace
for a couple hundred thousand dollars
now i'm probably exaggerating
but you could just spend the rest of
your and then you start a business down
there
just you know open a bar to pay your
bills or something
that's what i mean well i don't know if
i would i don't know if i want to open a
business because they're like money
socks but
well you need something to pay the
[ __ ] lights you know what i mean true
but if you're living somewhere that it's
kind of like i don't know i just kind of
feel like it's probably just better to
be low-key
and not like worry about [ __ ] that's
what happened to the uh that's what
happened to the italian mob
in the united states over time
most of them just went straight you know
a lot of them got killed but their
families survived and they had money and
they just bought restaurants and
nightclubs and
got involved in regular businesses
buried working people and yeah
if you have that much money yeah i mean
it just seems
easier to just do [ __ ] legitimately
normal [ __ ] yeah
because otherwise you're not just like
you're con you're not constantly
worrying about one the cops catching you
too like the [ __ ] rival gang like
shooting you in the face
you don't have to worry about hiding
what it is you do for a living
yeah it just seems like that seems like
stress i don't need
yeah yeah i can understand the
temptation of [ __ ] somebody doing
that
seriously have i considered robbing a
bank
absolutely yeah absolutely yeah you
wouldn't make it though i don't think
well i don't know yeah me you know how
you know how
uh how i overthink everything yeah so i
would plan the [ __ ] i would definitely
have more plans than this
than these [ __ ] have that's for
sure i'm not as dumb as you think i
wouldn't rob a bank
no i'm just saying that wouldn't be my
first go-to um
i understand the temptation because it's
like you know one and done
um you know it's like i only have to get
away with this one time
but you really have to like plan the
[ __ ] out of that because i don't think
it's as much money as you i don't
well and i don't think i don't know if
it's like worth it like the risk reward
thing is really not
be safer to get involved in some kind of
drug deal where you [ __ ] come up
about ten thousand or a hundred thousand
dollars and then just trying to walk
away from it yeah i kind of feel like
well i don't know a lot of people have
done that yeah
i don't know the thing about drug
dealing is that then you have to get
involved with other people that are
drug dealers and then you might like
fall afoul and it's like just this whole
thing and somebody might bump you off so
it's just kind of like
i understand the appeal of just doing
like a bank job
and then you know i don't i think it's
too
i don't think the reward is great enough
anymore
yeah i don't it just seems it's too hard
yeah it's too hard
um and honestly like like i said i'm
kind of i'm kind of
into like art heists or like diamond
heists and stuff like that
i admire the dudes that do that but
it's work the dudes that did the antwerp
diamond heist which maybe one of these
days will do a show about it because i
read a book about it and it's like
[ __ ] fascinating
but they planned for two years
yeah and they had there was a bunch of
them and they had all this [ __ ] they
had maps and [ __ ] [ __ ] it was a whole
it was like a movie
the problem yeah you know what i mean so
it was just kind of like that's oh
that's like
it's too much work it's too much yeah
you might as well just get a job
yeah and then the other thing is is that
you have to be willing to go to prison
well that's it because what ends up
happening with art heist and
heisting is that you steal the art and
then you have friends that hold it for
you
you wait till you get [ __ ] arrested
and you say i don't have it
but i think i know who does have it and
then he's [ __ ] then they send you the
[ __ ] jail well that's what the
gardener and then they sit there and
[ __ ] try to wear you down
and they're like you know i think for
the right price i can get that piece of
art back for you you
know well [ __ ] man that one dude they
interviewed him for the go
on that gardner-heist thing that was on
netflix right and that's basically his
whole interview yeah you can't admit to
st
stealing it but you have to be an art
specialist and you have to have a
[ __ ] long history of being credible
about yeah i know all about art
and you got to just [ __ ] to convince
them that well if you let me go
and you give me the right amount of
money i can go out there and i can find
that i'll show you where this is i'll
i'll find it for you well see the thing
about the gardner heist
like i said i want to do a show about
this for a while too but there was like
netflix did a a mini series about it
recently and i read a book about it a
couple years ago
the thing about that one is that one
seemed
very very specific like they did take
some [ __ ] that i don't was like
questionable
but most of the [ __ ] they stole it
almost seemed like
somebody gave them a uh like a list of
[ __ ] they wanted
you know what i mean because a lot of
the [ __ ] they stole was just kind of
like
maybe not [ __ ] that you would first go
to i mean they obviously kind of knew
what they were doing
so i kind of feel like and the fact that
the [ __ ] most of the [ __ ] hasn't
surfaced
that leads me to believe that somebody
somewhere
said hey go take this this this this
this
these are the ones that i want and then
he took them and sold them to that dude
i don't think they were trying to sell
them on the open market because why
would you what
uh well you can't sell it well that's
what i'm saying
so i feel like art heists is either for
a ransom
which that might have been yeah or
somebody somewhere like some rich ass
collector is like i have to have xyz
it's like please go steal these for me
from wherever usually and that's what
they
yeah it usually isn't that because or
like you said a lot of times it's like
random yeah it's all it's almost always
you steal the [ __ ]
it's a national treasure and you it's
you know the government of france will
do anything to get this [ __ ] thing
back
if you're willing to [ __ ] spend two
or three years in jail over the
[ __ ] okay and negotiating with them
they'll eventually let you out
and give you a bunch of money to go get
that [ __ ] picture back
yeah they know you know where it is you
haven't admitted to it though
because you can't all right but you
convince them that
if you let you out they give you the
right amount of money that that the
pitcher comes back
and then it does the dudes that dot that
do this have done it several times
but in every case they've done three or
four years sitting in jail
but that's kind of like well that's kind
of baked into
it i mean they're expecting to do yeah
that's kind of like you have to get
caught and go to jail
that's part of the negotiation yeah so
occupational hazard well that's part of
the plan yep
all right and uh that's how you protect
your your
your your uh your partners and they got
you
but that was the whole [ __ ] part of
the plan you got yeah you got me
but you don't have the painting yeah if
you let me go i think i can get it
though
you know if you give me the right amount
of money i can find it i think i know
who has well because in a lot of ways a
lot of those pieces of artwork are
uh more valuable yeah the people
involved exactly
so when they know that they know that
they know all that so they know that
you're they know they're going to get it
back
so they're it's like a battle of will
they're like how long you want to hold
this dude
before we get that painting back and
they go make that [ __ ] do four
years
but he doesn't care because you're going
to give him two million dollars
yeah i spent four years in prison for
two million dollars right and he's got
two million from the last time he did
this [ __ ] yeah
okay so like i said i can see what and
they're not going to put
you like in [ __ ] i mean it depends on
what country no they kept they they do
that [ __ ] [ __ ] they go to regular
[ __ ] general population that's what i
mean they're not gonna
it's not gonna be like some hardcore
[ __ ] no it's hardcore i mean yeah but
not like i've seen where they attended
that one dude it was somewhere in france
they just had him in general population
in like a central lockup
he wasn't convicted of anything so he
was in jail he wasn't in prison
okay which jails [ __ ] suck okay
so it's like a whole just a holding area
just waiting
yeah they don't they don't
they don't have any [ __ ] privileges
or anything but he doesn't care
he's gonna get two three million dollars
he's ransoming this [ __ ] off for
millions of dollars
so he's sitting in there doing tai chi
and mental [ __ ] powers and
doing it again you know i think i have
electric [ __ ] you know the main [ __ ]
sitting in there for four years even
funnier like
[Laughter]
about the painting oh yeah the painting
yeah yeah yeah the painting
you know i don't know where the painting
is
i had nothing to do with any of this
[ __ ] but i think i know who has it
he's gonna want money for it though yeah
he's gonna want about three or four
million dollars for this
he's gonna want four million dollars oh
you're not gonna let me out okay well
then just come back and call me when you
want the painting back i can get that
painting
it's like i'll just guess it yeah okay
yeah so you did this
waiting game but they know what he's
doing they're like make that
[ __ ] do five years
yeah but he doesn't care he wants the
four million dollars
yeah like i said i mean and then he he
would do [ __ ] like well the longer that
we make them
wait the more it's going to be so that
he starts putting pressure on them
interest i'm pretty sure they want their
money now
you know if you make me wait another six
months they probably put another million
on this
yeah you know it's gonna cost more
they have this whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
planned out yeah like i said people like
i i laughed because victor said
sometimes i wonder if i'm too old
to just quit my job and follow my dreams
and become an international art thief
don't think i haven't thought about that
because i got to know a lot about
you tell the fbi all about it no i'm
just saying that
i'm well i've always been interested in
particularly well because i'm like a big
like i'm really into
i'm really into it you have to know the
value of all that well i know but i see
i'm really
like into art and art history and stuff
like that so i've always been fascinated
by
you got to know all the people art
heists and i've always also been
fascinated by art
forgers i am super like fascinating
we've seen some
cases where they'll steal some [ __ ] but
then the guys go why'd they take that
that's not worth that much money and
they're like they took that but they
didn't take this this is worth more
so some people do this [ __ ] they don't
know what they're doing either that or
they have another reason for doing it
i kind of suspect the latter but
honestly
i'm kind i'm fascinated by art thieves
and jewel thieves also
but i'm also really fascinated by art
forgers i love
art forgers particularly han van
meegeren if you guys i've been wanting
to do a show about him for like forever
because i find him like fasting i've
read i've read like three or four books
about him and he's just like a fast he
he was most famous for like forging
vermeers and i love i read some books
about him
and i was really interested in like all
the technical [ __ ] about what he did to
like to get the paintings right
but also what i thought was super
awesome was that
he was really really hardcore about
getting
the forgery right like the first couple
times
like when he um you know was like hey
here's this vermeer that
he he didn't like forge a painting that
already existed
what he did was he would paint something
because vermeer
didn't really have that many existing um
artworks
remaining but like the ones that he had
were like super valuable
so he was kind of like well i'm gonna
paint ones
that that are like in that style but i
was like i'm gonna say that it was like
a lost vermeer
like so this is something he would have
painted and
we just found it so that's kind of like
what he did which was smart i thought
so he did that and then he would do all
this stuff like he'd bake it in the oven
and he would do all this kind of [ __ ]
and he would do that and then like
but after a while though oh [ __ ]
after a while
i love that after a while he just
totally got lazy and he was just kind of
like well
[ __ ] man it's anything i fart out and
like paint
they'll buy it because they think it's
really every mirror so he didn't like
give a [ __ ] anymore so it was like he
didn't even try to make him that good so
like a lot of the later forgeries were
like really really
terrible looking in hindsight but at the
time everybody's like just trying just
eating that [ __ ] up
and like actually uh the nazis bought a
bunch of them too like thinking they
were real
which i thought was very funny so we
done with this case
yeah you want to talk about some other
[ __ ] how long we've been streaming uh
two hours and 49 minutes so not that
long your your part is very crooked yeah
it's gotta be crooked because i'm
i'm glad i'm glenn danzig right now wait
does glenn danzig have
his parts over here see because he's got
he's got the side he's got this one
seriously anything you want anything
this world has to offer
i can give you if you
just reach out your hands say you will
right right right never mind yeah sure
xanada says i still don't know who dan
sick is
[ __ ] curious you these children yeah
[ __ ] glendale i should i show i
showed you
i showed i showed santa the [ __ ]
apocalypse now he loved that [ __ ]
victor said it's trt cher yeah yeah yeah
trt [ __ ]
that's another guy i showed him
apocalypse now he [ __ ] loved that
[ __ ] he watched that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
six times the
redux version but then i i showed him
[ __ ]
i tried to get him to watch conan
he couldn't get through it the first
time then the second time he said he
liked it but he fell asleep at the end
of it
i can't understand this [ __ ] and then he
won't watch he won't watch the thing
you keep saying well i'm gonna watch the
thing but he never gets the thing
is one of the best horror movies ever
yeah yeah it's really really good
you know who glenn danzig is man go
[ __ ] get
go get an album on there oh you can get
this [ __ ] on youtube
danzig 2 lucifuge he was in the
i like the misfits better but he
wouldn't like misfits that's horror punk
yeah it's like punk rock music now you
want you want [ __ ]
danzig 2. listen to that album dancing 2
and dancing 3.
dancing 4 was good too i mean dan's like
right right yeah dancing was good
it was metal yeah it was kind of special
kind of metal it was like a satanic
metal
type of special metal but it was kind of
like also
like the doors he kind of sounded a
little bit like
uh jim morrison jim morrison a little
bit yeah he's really into like jim
morrison i'm like yeah with 50
elvis and [ __ ] 50s and elvis although if
you really like the doors and you want
like some [ __ ]
80s [ __ ] echo and the bunnyman is where
it's at because echo and the bunnymen
are very very doris influenced
um victor said let's talk about art
theft
show them that this game right here pull
that out
oh man okay you can do it you can do
it don't break my [ __ ]
you're saying i can do it i may not be
able to do it
see that was your fault no it wasn't you
made me do it
no i made this game a while back
called boosting body jelly that's all
about art theft
and i'm in the process of making a
version of it
that is smaller that's just like a card
game it's going to be played kind of
like that and it's called something
different but it's kind of like not as
complicated
what did you knock off of there just a
little plastic mug yeah
mug up pick that mug up please
let me see it what are you worried about
this for it's a little plastic bot this
is my alligator farm
if you go to the alligator farm and you
buy one of these at the snack bar
you can refill your [ __ ] all day long
which is what i did because it was
[ __ ]
100 degrees that day and you're walking
around outside
so i was like well [ __ ] i'll pay seven
dollars and i'll just like [ __ ]
have ice and gender rail all day long
thank you but yeah so
so like i said victor i'm super into art
theft and like i said if you don't know
anything about han van reeve
migrant i want to do a show about him
one of these days maybe i'll have to do
it on one of the side track shows
because i find him like a fascinating
character
like it's not legal but you know that's
okay what do i knock over
all right
yeah um the thing about like
for whatever reason i think i brought
this up on maybe wednesday's show or the
show
the other day that i have pandora on my
phone because it was already in there
and i was
i already had an account so i was just
like whatever and
my station i literally have i think i
have like 50 different bands in there
but whenever i listen to it which is
every day because i listen to it when
i'm all
like walking and they play at least two
misfit songs
every single [ __ ] day he likes the
ramones and sex pistols so you probably
like the misfits
yeah i mean if you like ramones instead
koopas you know that's another thing
my pandora station plays a lot of
ramones yeah and not so much sex pistols
they play a lot of pil though
yeah i think i like dancing better
though than misfits i just i just do
yeah they're not a lot better yeah i get
that
i mean the misfits are very if you like
the ramones you should probably for sure
like the misfits because it's
i mean it's very simple but it's like i
don't know they're they're just
like really entertaining but yeah
my pandora plays a lot of misfits and a
lot of ramones
it's really weird because i think i
brought this up before and sophie was
like why don't you get like [ __ ]
spotify or whatever
i was just like well i already had a
pandora account i got my new phone
it already had a pandora app on it i was
like yeah whatever what the [ __ ]
so i just like i just wanted somebody to
listen to while i was hiking
so i went and listened to my station and
even though
my station is so weird because i have
like 50 like i said 50 to 100 different
bands on there
and it kind of runs the gamut um
you know i got punk i got like some 60
[ __ ] on there i got like [ __ ]
johnny cash on there and hank williams
and [ __ ] like that
but i also got like a lot of new wave i
got like
so i have all kind of different stuff so
i'm not really sure
if my radio station knows what to do
this morning
it played what did it play it played
rufus wainwright which is awesome
because i love him
then i played david bowie and then it
played
leonard cohen and then it played
the misfits and then it played
[ __ ] man what did it play after that
played a minor threat
and then it just and then it went off in
a punk rock direction
but sometimes like one morning the other
morning i went for a walk
and for the first half of my walk like
for like
half an hour it played like irish
folk punk which i guess because i put
the pogues
in there um so it played like pogue's
adjacent
stuff for like half an hour and then it
went into like new order and then it
started playing like new wave and stuff
but it's like it's bizarre how it gets
into these little
it gets into these little like moods
it's very strange and you never really
know like i'm okay with it because i'm
just like whatever
um i'll just like listen whatever mostly
it's very rare that like a song comes on
that i'm just like [ __ ] this and i skip
it
every now and then it happens i think
the one time it happened i was listening
to it in the car
and it played what's that [ __ ] band
that they
had it hot topic all the time h.i.m
okay so it started playing the song and
i was driving
and i was literally driving i was like
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] and i don't
usually do that
because i'm usually like whatever but i
was like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
what is this crap that it's like playing
on here and like when i parked and i
picked it up and i was like oh
okay and then i skipped it but that
pretty much
it's it's pretty good like it plays
whatever look at what look at you
yeah i'm trying to keep everything on my
face
oh my god wow i'd go to the club like
this
you should well this uh weekend
actually tonight what is it it's friday
right tonight and tomorrow night at
mannequins is goth apocalypse they're
doing a mad max
apocalypse theme so everyone's supposed
to like look like are we going to that
i don't know okay well we got to go out
monday yeah for memento so i don't know
if we're going out tomorrow night or not
yeah the kids are coming with us
the kids yeah yeah where's where are
they
she's not here she's not here tonight
you didn't say anything i
would ask them come over no i mean she's
not here in the chat
because she was here wednesday yeah
doing your thing we were like drunk and
i didn't even know we were talking about
which i'm drunk now but i still kind of
know what i'm talking about
mostly look at you with like two glasses
and i have four glasses
you're actually six eyes yeah
yeah we don't i don't know like i don't
are we going out tomorrow night
i don't know because we have to go out
monday night yeah the kids are gonna go
with us on monday night to memento mori
the kids might be at mannequins tomorrow
anyway they might be yeah
yeah if we told them to go they probably
would
like i said it's like i don't i'm not
going to do a mad max thing because i
don't think i have anything
time for that [ __ ] for that yeah i
forgot like last weekend was supposed to
be steampunk
and then i got there it's too [ __ ]
hot for bad max i have all those leather
jackets and all that [ __ ]
i got there and i was like oh yeah it's
steampunk and i did the [ __ ] poster
so you think i would remember but i
don't yeah i don't remember that stuff
i do so many posters xanada said my
sister is really into my chemical
romance
boo
[Laughter]
my chemical romance was one of those
things they're not awful it's just kind
of like
a generic yeah generic [ __ ] pie i
felt like that's kind of what happened
when you know when hot topic got real
popular when
goth kind of went mainstream in the 90s
then you got
it was really weird because i feel like
you had all of these kind of like kids
that looked sort of gothy or goth
adjacent right
but they all listen to like pop punk i'm
looking in here man
which is very strange i look like the
lead singer of [ __ ]
[ __ ] life life is
life yeah yeah
life life i thought you looked a little
bit like ian asbury
yeah sing firewoman
i forgot how that went how'd that go i
don't know i don't like the cult
they're one of the i liked them when
they were uh still kind of death rock
the southern death i liked them when
they were southern death
yeah once they went to the cult they
kind of went a little metally
kind of like how sister mercy went later
that first electric album was pretty
good
it was okay it was kind of like it's
kind of like a goth version of ac dc
yeah that's a good way of putting it
yeah
what you doing she's sniffing your wig
yeah prepper life is life gotta look
that up yeah it's
oh yeah live i like livestream life
life is life it's just this damn
gothic industrial german band and
they're all dressing up in this germanic
[ __ ] they're up in the [ __ ]
mountains with the snow and [ __ ]
goggles and [ __ ] hats and
leather [ __ ] and they're just it's just
it's a it's [ __ ] bizarre
real it's good though it's good it's
kind of like knit cereb
kind of like knits a rib d uh not as
darker
not as dangerous not as dancy dark
because i feel like nights or ever kind
of more like
like the club version of that [ __ ] but
liboc is more like
they're more towards like the einsteins
that i know about and yeah end of the
range what does it where is like i
started i started i know baton is more
like
you can't really dance to it because
it's just a lot of it's just like noise
although they got like they mellowed out
like later on but
i'll show it a lot of their [ __ ] like
you can't uh
dance to that really because it's just
like noise
but i like that so lie back is kind of
like
in between those things i guess they had
a couple songs that were kind of big
i don't know if i'd say they were big
club hits but they were kind of like
they got played at clubs a lot
you know life is life or you know what
it was
it was mostly in german i heard the
german version liba
something liba something liba i don't
speak german
[Music]
that's right i remember that i do i
really do like that song though
we're gonna get demonetized because of
that yes copyright
[Music]
he looks like vlad the impaler there
[Music]
oh that was it
life is life yeah
yeah xanada says emo is just a style my
sister has crazy colored hair and
dresses like a scene kid
yeah it's kind of like i don't know
i don't want to like [ __ ] on anybody but
that
that whole emo thing just so bummed me
out when that happened
i guess that kind of that kind of first
came to
you know popularity i guess in the 90s
and then i was just kind of like yeah i
don't really know i don't i don't like
where the shit's going
it's just i don't know it bummed me out
and are people still into that i guess
but it just seemed like it was weird
because it seemed like a lot of the kids
that were into that the [ __ ] they were
listening to
wasn't that different from what was
being played like what was
mainstream music right that's what
weirded me out about it it's like you
guys aren't that
you know you think you're all they were
kind of like doing the same [ __ ] like
with the attitude it's like oh we have
we're so different from like blah blah
but it's like the music they were
listening to is not
that different from what mainstream
people were listening to it just
like i said it just sounded like pop
punk at the time i
i went into hot topic and it's like it
would just be pop punk playing i'm
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] i don't
like this
i don't know but you know maybe that's
me
what are you doing trying to get back to
the stream making noise
well the the volume was turned on
because i was letting him listen that
song
life is life i want to hear that now
see that's the thing i don't know you
know what honestly i don't think i've
ever heard the english language version
that might be the first time yeah i had
it on my itunes for a long time but i
think it was the german version
hot topic ruined it yeah they did and
honestly hot topic used to be okay back
in the day like i used to be able to
find like some decent clothes there
way back in the day but
after a time it seemed like they just
kind of went
i don't know they were never playing
anything good when i went in there and
it's like then they were just kind of
like hey we're gonna do all t-shirts and
toys they didn't really have any good
clothes anymore
because i bought some clothes it started
to go down a direction that just wasn't
goth they
they had some good [ __ ] there for they
did a couple years
for a couple years it went pretty good i
mean i didn't grow up with it because we
didn't have a hot topic and
where i grew up until the two until
early 2000s maybe
well i i told in earlier shows that my
friend melissa
who who managed the [ __ ] store
down in biloxi ended up being kind of
like a regional manager
of hot topic because she was just gothed
out as [ __ ]
and they would do all these online
conferences back in the [ __ ] late 90s
when that [ __ ] was really high tech
and that's where they cooked up the damn
[ __ ] big-ass gothic jean coats the
big pants
yeah and they were going to chill like
all the time
and the reason why that all that
happened is because there weren't enough
goth kids to [ __ ] support
hot topic so you had to take what was
mainstream
and fuse that in with things that were
kind of like to make like kids think
that they were being rebellious
right right you take what they were
already wearing and kind of make it a
little bit good but then they said [ __ ]
that
they were wearing jinkos yeah remember
jenkos yeah big giant pants
big giant [ __ ] jeans yeah they're
like a skirt jean
i was too old for them yeah it was cute
back though that
they had cute girls though they were
wearing well you had to be a tiny
young little girl with a belly ring yeah
they would ring in your [ __ ] belly
and a [ __ ] wife and a little hat and
a little half shirt
and a half shirt and a tongue ring and
the half shirt
either had to be like flat chested
or you had to have [ __ ] great boobs
so the bottom of your boobs would be
poking out to the bottom of that [ __ ]
hat
they were [ __ ] cute as [ __ ] and they
were goth adjacent they would go out
with goth guys
but it's not really the same it's not
the same thing because grantham says is
emo basically goth light
no no really it's not really the same
thing exactly
it's hard to explain it was like a goth
type
offshoot but from our point of view it
was it came
kind of came out of nowhere and it was
kind of amateurish and it went away
quick
and like i said they were all it was
just kind of like to me
it seemed like they came out of nowhere
corporate
they were dressing sort of like goths
but also
kind of like with some other [ __ ] mixed
in that didn't make any sense
leg pants and they were also listening
to
[ __ ] like that was definitely not goth
green day
yeah they listened to green day and
avril lavigne maybe
yes like [ __ ] that was like real like
that
everybody this is kind of pop right
it was that was very strange it's kind
of like a gothic interpretation of pop
the best thing that they did listen to
though
was um the uh was what was that [ __ ]
interpol they didn't see i like interpol
was good they listened to that
and i liked interpol uh she wants
revenge they listened to that
i also liked it and that was good too
that was a that was a ba house ripoff we
met them at the [ __ ] club
we did yeah yeah very good
um well a starry night opened for them
yeah like no before
before yeah but we met them before yeah
yeah yeah they were they were at
uh at eyebar that's right
yeah everybody comes to eye bar yeah
or they they changed the name back to
barbarella so i have to call it
barbarella now
that's what it used to be called then
they changed it independent bar but
recently they changed it back to marvel
but that's what it used to be called a
long time ago but we'll see that's why i
didn't get the whole emo thing because
it just seemed to me
that it's like you guys are trying to
look like goth
sort of but you're not listening to any
gothic
music you're just listening to like pop
music
or punk music like pop punk like i said
they were listening
like green day and show like that which
you know that's fine
but i didn't get it i didn't really get
the connection
it was it had kind of become divorced
from i mean the aesthetic had kind of
become divorced
from the music at that point yeah and so
i didn't really
so that i think that's what pissed me
off more than anything else
because people were just kind of like uh
commandeering the look without anything
behind it
but no i'm just confirming what xanada
said no some of the some of the emo
girls were were really cute
they were cute they weren't goth though
no it's not really the same thing no not
really the same thing they were cute
they were
from our point of view they were
mainstream
they were close but like i said they
were all like little avril lavigne's
kinda yeah which was like she was in the
[ __ ] top 40 right yeah
yeah that was just regular pop music
there wasn't anything like weird or edgy
or nothing like that about that
they some of them even had good hair um
they had kind of good tasting clothing
some of them but like i said it wasn't
goth
it was almost very 60s inspired
you know you notice that was almost like
something that like maybe they're
listening to the monkeys or something
daydream sleeping yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like hey tila's in the house
wow i just walked in the door and
y'all's still on of course we are
[ __ ] at the end of the show it's only
three hours
come on the end of the show and t just
[ __ ] walks in here [ __ ] man we
already finished talking about the
topic yeah in the show t
walks in here dropping her tits like a
[ __ ] gangster
boom letting letting gravity [ __ ] let
gravity do its work
what are you doing at t look did you see
did you start um spartacus yet wait a
minute tila says
i saw a dog get hit by a car today holy
[ __ ]
sad but he survived and okay well she
shouldn't be and i hope so
i ran over a raccoon and when i was
[ __ ] coming back from the club one
time
remember that and all these brothers and
sisters saw it happen
and i was just like oh that was the
worst couldn't stop in time there's no
way
they just ran the raccoons ran into the
side of the car
basically yeah there's just no way to
stop yeah i remember that
and i [ __ ] looked in my rearview
mirror and he's laying in the road and
all of his [ __ ] brothers and sisters
are going whoa oh and i was like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
stopping awful couldn't handle it
couldn't handle it because it was
unintended that was some unintended [ __ ]
it's awful yeah but uh i live in fear
because one night i was coming home from
work i wasn't even drunk or anything but
i used to work like night shift and so
i'd be coming home at like 2 30 three in
the morning
and a dog literally jumped
into my bumper and i ran over him
and i stopped obviously and like i got
out of the car but then i couldn't find
him so i guess he ran off
but i was just kind of like man i hope
that [ __ ] yeah
i hope that [ __ ] dog made it uh
granthar's hammer said if some emo girls
showed up at eyebar would they be
shunned
i don't think anyone shone them no some
of them goth girls in there you could
tell we're emo girls a long time ago
yeah yeah i mean they still can't
sometimes kind of carry a little bit of
the of the look
yeah you still see it because
particularly memento mori which is kind
of more the goth industrial night where
you get a slightly younger crowd
yeah um eyebar saturday night is kind of
a mixture of kind of
younger uh sort of like
just regular people and then like older
goth people
but momento mori is kind of like older
goth people but then like
young like kids that got into it in the
90s and 2000s
yeah so you do get some like emo
carryover yeah
um and nobody is like [ __ ] on it no
the key
the cute emo girls from like the mid
2000s you know like 2005 2000 2008
12 around that time 2012 maybe too late
but 210
2010. they wore cute boots
that would have been like goth friendly
they wore little bitty pointed like what
we call pixie boots
that were very aggressive and real high
with a little spiked heel and they were
kind of a short
a little bit above the ankle it's kind
of like the little skull boots you had
they weren't
[ __ ] like that but of different colors
with little [ __ ] peg leg [ __ ]
black pants and they had
they had a decent aesthetic the good
ones
some of them the problem was the male
fashion
what the guys wore just was [ __ ]
terrible terrible
i had more of a problem with like the
music than that yeah the music wasn't
that good
most of the clothes looked alright yeah
blaster one asks do you guys like slayer
or
pantera i like slayer yeah i don't know
yeah i like slayer yeah
especially like uh my favorite one was
um
my favorite slayer album and i had i had
hella weights that was a pretty good one
um what was it called
um not raining blood
it was the one with war ensemble in it
and [ __ ]
um [ __ ] what was it it had a [ __ ]
spooky ass terrible
looking cover had war ensemble
and um
hello and hello no not hella weights
what the [ __ ] was he
you probably know better than me man but
it's been a long time that was about
that was around uh yeah tom was a metal
guy 1990 yeah i started off actually
metal liking metal music and then went
into new wave
and then then gothic and then for a
while it was like all of them at the
same time
yeah because a lot of that stuff was
happening at the same time there was
even crossover slightly
like very early the first album of
motley crew
was kind of like a goth rock album it
had a goth rock
look to it they were wearing girls
clothes their girlfriend's clothes and
their weird [ __ ] hair
later on you started seeing [ __ ] like
some of the early goth bands kind of had
that same look too
well i guess there was a lot of like
glam rocket landings look at like like
new york dolls and stuff like that had
that kind of look like in the early 70s
some of the stuff from like early susie
and the banshees and susie kind of
looked like something out of very early
motley crew
it was it was there was a lot of
crossover yeah there wasn't as large a
distinction back then
no you knew that it was a different
thing it's just that they were borrowing
from they were playing off each other
yeah and like i think i mentioned this
on our golf show but it's kind of like
when i was
i mean when we were growing up in the
80s and early 90s
um because there were so few people that
were into
goth punk post bonk whatever um you kind
of tended to hang out together
even if you weren't into the exact same
[ __ ] it wasn't as
yeah that's right season's in the abyss
that's what the name of that album there
you
go
seasons of the abyss they had another
one that came out later i think it came
out like
94 or 95 and it came in a damn
metal sleeve that went over the cover it
was
bluish bluish metallic blue
kind of color and black album it was
really good too which i remember what it
was
oh [ __ ] around 95. that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
badass it was even harder
94 95 around that time
yeah i mean the thing like you had a
slightly different because you kind of
got
you were into metal and then later got
into
you know goth and wave and stuff whereas
i kind of started out
when i was little started out with a new
wave and then went into gotham punk
yeah right so it's kind of like i got
into like you're older than me but i got
into like gotham punk before
a little bit before you did um icarus 72
said susie is awesome i agree
yeah uh and also early mid 80s new wave
was awesome
it i mean i still listen to that [ __ ]
nowadays i never get sick of it
never tila asks a random question
toilet paper under or over over
over yeah he does it under
whenever he puts it on the right which
is not that often
but okay name of that album that i was
talking about was called divine
intervention
that [ __ ] was good too really good
album oh okay
i had the very first slayer album i can
see being into that kind of show like i
was never super into metal but i can see
why people would be into that
the very first slayer album was called
uh face the slayer
oh no no uh that was the the first song
on it it was called uh
[ __ ] what was the name of their very
first album it's called i don't know
what are you asking me for
i'll see yeah you have a google thing
like right in front of you
it's like i love this he you have
in your hands right there you have all
the accumulated knowledge
of humankind it's called show no mercy
[ __ ] 1983. and yet he still asks me
yeah i'm like [ __ ] i don't know i'm not
google
when when show no mercy came out in 83
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] mind-blowing
during that same time i was also
listening to venom i had
like uh black metal uh [ __ ] um
uh what was it called a thousand days in
sodom was one of them and
welcome to hell those three albums and
they were [ __ ] badass and then slayer
came out of nowhere with
with with show no mercy we're like what
the [ __ ] is this
it was really fast and really hard
you know and it was almost kind of like
a [ __ ] really intense punk rock music
when
when
we first heard it it to me it was like
it was like iggy pop's first album
[ __ ] raw power it was like that but
on on [ __ ]
which is one of the best which is really
good it was like that but it was like on
meth
you know i was like whoa what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] and uh slayer helped change
the game
and then a few months after that
album came out that dudes that i had
never heard of they were called
metallica it was called kill them all
and i remember when that came out that
was like a big deal we were all [ __ ]
blown away by this new [ __ ] band and
then it just seemed like a few months
later something called ride the
lightning came out and that album just
blew your [ __ ] mind
in the 80s when ride the lightning came
out and we i knew that metal had changed
now like i said two years later i was
listening to sisters of mercy
yeah or a year or so later i was this
but
i would still enjoyed all that metal it
had its place that was like conventional
the god stuff was new that was like very
unconventional from
the american perspective and it was
starting to come in
i was like starting to get old enough to
appreciate
the nuances that were happening inside
of like the sisters of mercy and bauhaus
well the thing about like i said metal
is cool but it just seemed kind of
seemed like
goth post punk [ __ ] like that yeah that
was more like
experimental yeah and that was kind of
like what i was into
uh louis was saying scott was big when i
was in high school
i'm alex got to um and somebody said you
were a gen xer i am as well
i was born in 1972. uh the toilet paper
issue everyone's like over
thank you for agreeing with me because
that's the only correct thing
uh under is just i don't know it's too
much of a pain in the ass i don't know
why people do it like that
uh filmer grimm iii asked where the sex
pistols goth no um
goth was a very specific thing the sex
pistols
were punk but the interesting thing
about the sex pistols is they were
almost like manufactured punk
because even before they got famous
i mean there had been other punk singles
before that very famously probably the
first punk single that came out
like as a single was the damned right um
who i actually love and i still love the
damn to this day now the damn did like
punk rock [ __ ] earlier but then they
kind of went post-punky gothy kind of
later
uh they did an album called
phantasmagoria which came out in what
85.
yeah it was that was a very goth rock
album it's like i love that [ __ ]
album
uh and that's nick cave's wife on the
cover there before they
met uh fun fact but um yeah that's a
great album but i also like i like all
their old punk rock [ __ ] too i mean like
[ __ ]
man new rose all that kind of [ __ ] i
love those [ __ ]
singles so punk rock had been going on
for a while like i think
sex pistols i like the sex pistols
the sex pistols were old when i heard it
and that was 77.
well and they had been yeah they had
been around since 75 76 something like
that
so uh i kind of feel like by the time
that punk rock
came over to the u.s it was already like
over in the uk hey anakrae if you like
this
shirt man just send me a 20 super chat
and i'll make you one
we make these it's even labeled 13
o'clock on the back you can't see it
because of my [ __ ] because of your
beautiful
my beautiful long beautiful hair
[Laughter]
you're beautiful but uh now we make
these you can see right there
did you make that and yeah i made this
one too yeah
but twenty dollars if you're in the
continental united states i can send you
one of your choice
in terms of size
okay yeah scott says the damned rule i
agree
um honestly i've liked pretty much
everything and like the damned have gone
in a bunch of different directions like
i said they started out as kind of like
a punk rock band and then they went like
post punk they did some goth [ __ ]
and then later in the 2000s they went
kind of more in a psycability kind of
direction and i was into that as well
if you don't have their album uh when
did it come out 2004 i want to say it
was called grave disorder it's actually
really really good
uh i actually really really love that
album i listen to it all the time
but yeah so uh yeah they've been around
forever and
i really really like them um you guys
should make a video on john lang
if we haven't that's not familiar
but yeah i don't know who that is i
don't know who that is uh icarus 72 says
the cult
woo um i'm like
you like you're into the cult they they
were good they had they had uh i like
the southern death cult the very first
white album they had that one that was
good yeah i'm kind of more into them
when they were like more definitely
just kind of yeah like southern and they
did like the fat man single and all that
kind of stuff
then that um the cult electric album
came out i was in brazil at that time it
was a really good time
my life that was like i was a senior
year
in sao paulo brazil [ __ ] going to the
international high schools listen to
that
right alongside with duran duran's
notorious and [ __ ]
billy idols whiplash smile yes i was
listening to all that around the same
time and [ __ ] the cult [ __ ] really
that cult electric album really kind of
blended in with with the
sounds of the time it was good that was
before
no i had heard i know i i i had already
heard uh sisters of mercy i was
listening to that
and i was listening to um the bauhaus
albums
yeah so it did kind of play in at that
time i liked it
um to me i kind of thought of it as a
a slightly more gothic version of ac dc
without the guitar solos
uh yeah kind of like a little bit harder
version of
of of early sisters of mercy like first
last and always
i liked it but i also knew that it was
commercial
i think that's the reason i couldn't
really get all that like i like it
but i don't i couldn't get as into it
it's kind of like i couldn't get into
it was like motley crue it was
commercial yeah yeah
it was kind of it was good but it was
just good i didn't really have like a
lot of connection to it because it just
sounded like
too much like everything else even
though billy ida was was a bigger band
than that
billy ida was a lot more underground
feeling
than than yeah then cult had weirdly
in a weird way yeah like to me billy
idol will always be
[ __ ] underground he just if you don't
like it [ __ ] you that's the way he wrote
those songs
or bought those songs he was being
himself
it wasn't really a um
it wasn't really a pop music thing even
though pop
liked him you know i mean he was in top
40
easily he was top 10 a couple times
with eyes without a face it's like i'm
always kind of more into
you know bands that sort of like stumble
into popularity yeah
rather than like pursuing popularity
yeah right
and for me that would be billy idol he
just kind of stumbled into it it was
i mean and partially an accident and he
had cred also
he was involved he was in gen x it's
like he wasn't really he hung out with
the
susie sue he hung out with like all the
he knew these guys from the sex pistols
right
so he was a real punk rocker and he was
a kid he was [ __ ] on heroin and you
know he was not
the squeaky clean guy he was
a british [ __ ] street kid really you
know um
from the wrong side of the tracks making
it big in america and
he was high most of the time he'll tell
you that
i kind of feel like everybody was back
then but he was a great performer
and yeah he had the right look and he
cared about his fans and the music and
he cared about his shows and steve
stevens
was a great backup was a great backup
and support for him
if it wasn't for steve stevens the billy
idol you know would have never happened
i
that a lot of that had to do with
stevens his sound
and uh the the accessibility of good
songs they were buying they bought a lot
of the good songs or
paid to have them cleaned up you know
billy could write some things but he
wasn't a musical genius
um but you know like eyes without a face
was kind of cleaned up you know
well the thing about it is that if you
get picked up by
a major label then
you're going to have like a bunch of
people looking at your [ __ ]
and saying hey we need to like hire
these producers and like fix all this
[ __ ] up
because you can't just like put out some
[ __ ] like you know
it's that kind of thing so i can see how
that happens
yeah but you know um all right so
he's starting to try about time to
[ __ ] end the stream anyway probably i
want some meatloaf
yeah i'll go i'll get us something to
eat you ready and i'm on like my third
drink well actually it's kind of like my
sixth strength because you look like big
giant ones
i'm still like coherent though when we
got through the whole [ __ ] case yep
i'm so
proud of myself all right so if you guys
uh when's the next time we're streaming
uh sunday sunday sunday and we're going
to be talking about
the movie split yeah
if you haven't seen if you haven't seen
unbreakable and split go ahead and watch
those
and uh they're [ __ ] great super
honestly we watched split last night
yeah it was i had seen unbreakable
several times and i had seen
glass yeah but i had never seen split
yeah so we watched it last night and
you know what out of the three i think i
like that one the best yeah
hey tila i was meant to ask you did you
see
um spartacus yet i gave you she
mentioned
earlier that it's like i she thought
that she was supposed to watch bronson
first
uh tom gives you rules you have to
adhere to them
okay well you can get bronson out of the
way pretty quickly
all right but the thing is is that you
really have to see bro
yeah whatever i would see i would uh
i would see clockwork orange before you
see bronson
well it does inform bronson if you
haven't seen clockwork orange you have
to see that
well i don't you don't have to but it's
like it does really like kind of inform
you kind of understand what they're
doing a little bit i don't know like the
older i get
i'm just kind of like look because like
look you guys here's an example
a movie i rev that i just watched
yesterday and that i reviewed
that will be going up next week at some
time was this movie called piercing
and that movie very very directly
references
a bunch of different dario argento
movies can you enjoy this movie without
knowing what it's referring to sure but
if you watch the dario argento movies
beforehand
it's like a much better richer
experience
so i don't know it's kind of a hard
thing
because i'm old so it's hard like for
younger people i know they don't have
like
you know the the time or the experience
they haven't had like all the years on
the earth
yeah to have like watched all this [ __ ]
beforehand and they're just like hey
i get that reference hey i get that
reference like i get that yeah
but in a lot of ways i think you're
missing out on a lot of stuff if you
don't
yeah but t look
the thing is with spartacus is that
spartacus is a series
and there's four seasons of that you
don't have to watch that [ __ ] solid
you know what i mean and the first
episode of spartacus
is not it's not really the story really
it doesn't really start kicking off
until like episode two and three doesn't
it
from spartacus yeah i mean the first
episode you got to see that because it's
kind of like set up
it's set up right but yeah the first
one's like not fantastic because that's
all but they had to kind of like set
everything up right
i was watching the very first episode
and i was like i don't know if i'm gonna
like this series
then the second episode went oh this is
gonna be pretty good
and then it just consistently got better
and better and better throughout every
season
even though the star dies in real life
from cancer
yeah at the end of season two another
thing is
it's not real linear the first couple
seasons are in order but then they gotta
[ __ ] do it they they they they go
back
and um i think it was in season three
right yeah
and season three they or is this no
season two
season two is a um flashback
isn't it or is that season three that's
i think it was season three
yeah you'll see well because i think it
was because the character like batiatas
and all that was like so
popular you had to know whatever you had
to like go back and do a prequel because
of what it what happened yeah you know
so you can watch
what i'm saying is because that's four
seasons of material
you can watch some spartacus and then
throw bronson in there but i would see
i would see um i would do what she said
well she's already seen clockwork okay
then yeah go see bronson then
i mean bronson is like it's in the same
ballpark yeah
it's not quite like clockwork orange but
it's kind of like in the same box yeah
they they think you've seen a clockwork
orange already you'll see what i'm
talking about
we'll see that's a well that's the thing
like the older i get
i'm kind of like i just assume
everyone's seen clockwork orange because
it's a [ __ ] classic right and i just
assume that it's one of those movies
that everybody's seen
but i take it for granted that like
people that are maybe in their 20s
have never seen it and then after
bronson you want to throw in eventually
you want to see [ __ ] uh
legend about the crepe well yeah not
not the one with the devil and although
you should see that one too because that
was awesome
the one with tim curry is the devil no
it's the one with [ __ ] reggie ronnie
created it yeah
that's a good one too that's all british
true crime stuff
yeah that was actually good although
like i said the movie that came out
i can't remember what year it came out
but it was just called the craze i think
it felt in the 90s
but i put spartacus up at the [ __ ]
top and they
they got that on amazon prime is it for
free on amazon
i think it is wait which one spartacus
no i don't think we pay but there's ads
yeah there's ads on it yeah
but you got amazon prime you can see
that yeah you can watch it
yeah it's good but i was just thinking
about split because we watched split but
like yeah we had to pay for that but i
think it was only four bucks
yeah but yeah yeah somebody's talking
about james mcavoy yeah he's
he's amazing he was in the x-men movies
too and he was also in last king of
scotland
somebody mentioned that uh he was also
good he he's like a really good actor
and honestly like i said i had never
seen split but i think that's like my
favorite one of the trilogy now
yeah because i don't know uh
victor garcia says take shelter is on
prime i keep but that's on my list man i
keep meaning to [ __ ] watch that
i will get around to it i promise i
promise
all right so you ready to wrap it up yep
we went for three three and a half hours
and we covered the [ __ ] and we're not
too
inebriated and i'm starving yeah it's
kind of ready
so we will be back on sunday talking
about
the movie split probably
so thank everybody for dropping by
have a good weekend and we will see you
on
sunday afternoon bye